joshie he's gonna bring us up to date
with just I mean Sky News radio it's a
central part of what we do here now
Ashish yeah it's a huge part of what we
do here and perhaps people don't
completely realize just how big the
radio operation at Sky is when you think
the skies think sky TV you think online
digital but in fact there are millions
and millions and they've Terrace the
radio it will tell us exactly how many
numbers were involved Sky News Radio
huge operation just one of the numbers
give us the overview so skies radio
caters for commercial radios that are
about 300 radio stations in the UK and
the last audience figures are available
suggest that nearly 36 million people
listen to commercial radio the nation
really loves radio so our job is to
provide national and international news
to all those commercial radio stations
for them to be able to complement their
own local news gathering so what we do
here we use the might of the sky news
news gathering operation and we convert
that into radio material so we write
radio scripts we take radio clips
designed for bulletins and we also do an
on the our top of the hour bulletin
which is exactly two minutes every
station as the options are opt into that
but most will opt in out of hours so
evenings and weekends when stations are
staffed some stations do staff 24 hours
others don't so during the day stations
we use this primarily as a news resource
but in the evenings and overnights and
weekends they'll use us for the
bulletins as well and there are all the
new digital demands as well people might
be listening on their smart devices
that's right you can ask all these smart
speakers elects Amazon Elector Google
home for the latest news from Sky News
and what will come up is the latest
bulletin that we produced at the top of
the hour which is exactly two minutes do
your clients tell you what they want to
serve their audiences or or do you tell
them that this is what's happening today
and this is what we'll be providing I
think it's a bit of both actually so we
have we're instinctively focused on
Commerce stories which you which will
cater for commercial radio so we'll have
a discussion about that Charlie you've
just got any more do a random ring
around in a moment to talk to some of
the stations about what they're liking
then we'll base our news gathering on
that we tend to have a good feel for
what commercial mr. Dave I've got to
leave you because I'm going to join one
of your radio reporters Laura who is
preparing to put a bulletin together so
hopefully we can walk across the
newsroom floor this is Paul Harrison on
the home desk you saw him earlier in
that meeting the reason I'm trying to
hurry is because I've got to get to that
radio studio before Leela if you can get
the doors open this is Lila she's an
output producer she's helping me today
so we're gonna walk in and hopefully
Laura will be about to go on air hi
Laura this is Laura she's about a RN and
Sky News radio
from the Stinney Center at 8:00 a fire
in central Paris has killed at least
eight people one woman's been arrested
as Simon English reports around 200
firefighters were called to a
residential building in the art market
16th arrondissement overnight the
district is home to famous museums
understood the city's wealthiest
residents more than 30 people were
injured around 20 were rescued from
windows or nearby roofs as flames left
into the night sky prosecutors say this
breaking these and a hundred HIV stores
had been bought by Canadian retailer
sunrise records saving almost 1500 jobs
but 27 stores will close with immediate
effect with 455 redundancies the world's
first Minister for suicide prevention
says there's no doubt social media is
playing a part in the number of young
adults it's affecting the latest figures
show more than 5,800 people took their
own lives in the UK in 2017 on Safer
Internet day Jackie Doyle price says the
normalization of this content online
places a risk particularly in younger
people the internet generation people
access information all the time using
their own devices and so what starts off
as feelings of anxiety and depression
will leave people to Theresa May is
expected to acknowledge brexit as a
concerning time for those in northern
islands in a speech today she's due to
insist she can get a withdrawal deal
which avoids a hard border with the
Irish Republic actor Liam Neeson has
been accused of racism by online critics
after revealing he once went looking for
a black person to kill after a friend
was raped
he admitted walking the streets with a
weapon for about a week to seek revenge
in sport Liverpool missed the chance to
go five points clear at the top of the
Premier League last night they were held
to a 100 draw by West Ham at the London
Stadium that's the latest I'm Laura safe
hey Laura how'd it go is it
nerve-wracking anyway thinking that when
you're putting out one of your four isms
tens of millions of people are listening
to your every word not really no not
anymore and it is when I think about it
too much but you get used to it do you
ever get recognized for your voice
no no not really sometime have in the
past but when I was working in some
commercial radio stations and things
like that you seem to be quite
self-contained you write your scripts
you control all the equipment that's a
lot of demand and it feels quite
pressurized yeah - so we all write
scripts and then we all check each other
scripts and then I just pick what I want
to put in the bulletin every hour and
then just callate the bulletin so about
six stories and a couple of clips as
well so did you say you were choosing
the stories you want to point your
bulletin so that's left up to you yeah
so I put them in and then I just double
checked with the desk out it said that
he's fine with it or she's fine with it
and then if they want to change anything
then they'll just let me know that just
they've just swapped something around or
changed something slightly hopefully
there are going to be lots of aspiring
journalists watching Channel five to
three today and they haven't quite made
up their minds on whether they want to
be print journalists or radio journalist
of TV journalists is there a completely
different set of skills you need to be a
radio journalist if you wanted to be a
TV journalist for example with radio I
guess it's just with more immediate than
in television you don't need a camera
you can just record anywhere on your
phone anything and so essentially
journalism is the same yeah it's exactly
yeah scripts are just slightly tighter
sometimes the audiences are slightly
different for radio than they are for
television depending on who you're you
know audiences if you're working for
certain commercial radio stations
they're not be different one top tip for
an aspiring radio journalist mmm listen
to like take loads of advice ask loads
of questions
and listen to everybody tells you to say
thank you very much for giving us an
insight into the world of radio Neil
Ashish thanks very much and thank you
Laura did you see they're heading two
minutes past II absolutely second on is
this giving you an idea of why we find
this business so exciting and just take
you back to there today ed to the
morning meeting at half past 7:00
editorial meeting there was we look at
pictures from inside the gallery as a
sunrise continues its shortened to the
last note of sunrise in fact employee
spending a bit of time with the sunrise
team after they're sure as well but
let's just go back to that editorial
meeting and the point of it I mean as we
were describing it is about flagging up
what the big stories of the day are and
working out how we're going to do them
who's going to do them and and how we
get them on air but it's also there are
also a few technical terms that might
have been mentioned there one of yous
been in getting in touch and if you have
got any questions leave them using the
hash tag that you can see the bottom
right of the screen that's going use raw
at one question was what is bidding it
was mentioned an awful lot during that
morning meeting are we gonna bid for
this are we going to bid for that that
in essence means we're just going to try
and speak to them we bid for an
interview and so whenever you hear some
people saying using that particular
phrase that's what we're talking are we
bidding for the foreign office I'll be
bidding for at Liam Neeson's agent are
we'd be abetting for X Y Zed so that's
keep your questions coming in and we're
just having a quick look around the
newsroom and as you can see a she she's
just stamp pricing so I'll give her a
minute or two T to get himself settled
but the central to any news organization
particularly television news
organization are the desks the home desk
and the foreign desk the foreign desk
deals with everything that is there
outside of the UK at the home desk
everything domestically and of course
different days have different news
agendas at different days there are big
stories outside of the UK that we would
you choose to lead on but but in general
the bulk of our news that comes from
your hand via the home desk our series
of butyl up and down the country James
Matthews
optimist Scotland many people who very
familiar with Jarrett Arbor from the
Northeast as well and all of them being
brought in by the home desk being
allocated and allocated a story to
proceed with an and after that point you
know depending on the story sometimes
you're pretty much left to your own
devices I'm just going to see with
putting nurses back in because he's
going to be chatting to that chair
that's standing there with the phone to
Zia Paul Harrison and he was formerly
one of our royal correspondent formerly
our royal correspondent a big fan of red
trousers and she asked me not to mention
all here today those two facts entirely
unrelated of course but now of course as
home news editor he sets the tone sets
the agenda and tells
correspondents what to do a she she's
yeah she's good let's go pester Harrison
for a while shall we let's go and talk
to poorhouse and pester probably not it
might be a little bit I've been told to
pester you by Neal you've been told it'd
be nice to me
we heard you in the morning meeting
yesterday you're the man in the the hots
driving the news agenda as it were today
lots of responsibility on your shoulders
do you ever worry about just how much is
going on and how you're going to on a
day-to-day basis every day there's a lot
going on today so it is a juggling act
as any news editor would know on any
newspaper or or news channel it's it's
about making sure you don't drop a ball
if you can help it
that you've got the right people doing
the right stories being in the right
place at the right time I was going to
say is it a question of logistics moving
your assets around to meet the demands
which are being made constantly of you
by your outputs yes it's a bit like this
is this is the the pressure point if you
like from making sure that the programs
get what they want when they want it
that's we're not forgetting that there
are other things that are required from
the reporters the camera crews
engineers because you know the planning
are looking at tomorrow so I've got
pressures for tomorrow the day after
tomorrow the pressures for now and so
it's about making trying to make sure
everyone gets a decent bite of the
cherry obviously the focus has to be
principally on today because we're
having to do the news now having to
react stuff that we don't know about
obviously we're doing the things that we
do know about that things will happen
through the day and what our viewers
will know is that you are a
correspondent a legion an army of fans
of a royal correspondent travel the
world how different does it feel to be
here and does that give you a completely
different skill set you understand the
pressures on your teams out in the field
is that what you bring to this job I
think I think that having worked in the
field does help to then come on the news
desk and therefore you do have a bit of
an understanding about what it's like in
in the field I can just feel my my phone
vibrating now as we speak it's the one
thing you don't think that at all Apple
actually having having been on air
before for four rounds of 12 13 14 years
or so you do understand the kind of
pressures the demands obviously they are
different now I think the demands are
greater now so you have to bear that in
mind because of all the platforms that
you have to provide for it's not just
telly its mobile it's online it's radio
and so there are a great number of
pressures on not just the reporters you
have to remember that behind the
reporters and the correspondents there
is a team of cameras engineers
it's a massive team effort and are you
gonna make sure everyone doesn't get run
ragged I'm gonna go and talk to one of
your colleagues in a minute but just
before we go I'm sure lots of people
won't wanted a show
miss bring out the feel do you like
being on a news desk I do especially on
days like today when it's raining I'm
sure all of your correspondence out in
the field who are standing in under a
cloud will thank you the other reason I
came up there is that I have to leave it
to the good-looking ones
David baby Thank You polite you very
busy I'll leave you alone I'm gonna talk
to your colleague on the foreign desk
mrs. Andy Marshall was just talking to
Peter D a person some instructions from
the foreign desk to the floor as much as
anything else actually just you know we
did am an interview with John Oliver in
the States yesterday and it was about
whether there was a one camera two
camera shoe which basically affects our
sort of editing capabilities and what we
can actually do with it your job as a
song to pour Houston on the home dress
is it the same sort of job it's all
change because of your geography and
your ream it's much larger than that
well it is but then we're not sort of
we're not self reliant on gathering
picture so I think on a domestic level
on the home desk it's like if is a story
that develops in whatever is whether
it's you know whether it's wig and all
the West End the sky responsible for
gathering their own picture and voices
we do deploy on stores such as Venezuela
we've deployed on I mean that there are
two classic examples today Venezuela
we've got two teams deployed on that
which we will gather our own material
but we also have sort of partnerships
with with broadcasters over there and
agencies and that sort of supplements
because obviously we can't get
everything on such a wide scale and then
the other sort of headline story today
is the fire in Paris which we've sort of
taken a active decision not to go at the
moment because it's a it's a it's a
straightforward sort of tragic event
keeping an eye but we will gather
pictures from we have partners with our
French partners we do picture exchanges
with so we can still tell that story but
we don't actually have to go to gather
it ourselves and I suppose because
you're working across so many time zones
at the back your mind your
weary of waking up that correspondent in
the middle of the night and making that
call and having to live with that
decision all the time I guess and yeah
and quite often you you wake people up
unnecessarily but sometimes you've gotta
wake so you've got to speak somebody it
if there's an earthquake in when
whatever territory it might be in the
middle of the night you've got it it's
almost like you've got a err on the side
of caution and if you need to get
somebody moving and somebody up on that
you cannot be behind the curve so you've
got to call them and I think they they
live with that as a way of life for most
and I suppose Andy you're thinking all
the time as well when you're deploying
correspondents into hostile zones you
always thinking about risk management as
well yes yeah I mean more and more I
think and I would say over the last ten
years this sort of the whole risk
assessment side of things as really come
to the fore so we have we have
procedures in place not just on a sort
of administrative level but also very
much on a practical level as well and I
would say the majority of people who
work on on this desk and certainly on
the planning side of things have all
been deployed sort of hostile
environments so there is a you need an
element a sort of basic background
knowledge I was talking to Paul a little
earlier on and a little similar you were
out in the field years newsgathering
experience you're in Brussels as the
bureau chief there do you miss being on
the road or do like being behind a desk
I certainly missed the adrenaline of it
and and and under pace I think when
you're on the desk it's a little more
life is a little more predictable and
stable but what we try and do here is
and I think the people who had best at
this job are people who have operated in
the field and vice versa the people who
are best in the field are also connected
to the newsroom and understand how it
works so we try and mix we try and mix
it up a little bit so you got a bit of
this but then also getting out and about
just two stories as and when appropriate
I did 10 years non-stop on the road
which was you know which is quite that
can be quite draining so it's quite nice
to have a bit of a you know to pull back
a little bit and have a better balance
and thank you very much Andy little
insights into how Sky News manages its
award-winning foreign news operation and
that's the thing you often forget
working at Sky News when I first started
I was surrounded at Westminster by
people like Peter Lorre who you've
already seen Adam Bolton the people who
have worked for Sky News and Andy
marshes he was saying there's work for
Sky for 16 years have an incredible
amount of speed experience and it is
really I think it's almost almost
impossible to find a senior member of
staff who isn't keen on helping everyone
I mean auntie Marsh was you might
remember Alex Crawford's roared into
Tripoli she was a he was on that he was
on that four by four weather making sure
that coverage happened his six years
that took place at the six years that he
was working in Brussels any number of
stories now what were having a looking
at the moment is the mobile makan firm
that you can see there in the middle
screen at leading that daunting so let's
have a listen and see another part of
Sky News in the way that it prioritizes
and once I how we tell the story
yeah you need to remember yep
to switch them on that yeah that's
dangerous that's probably good idea yeah
yeah okay I better make a note okay what
else we've got
Ronan is obvious way back from Poland
we'll be back in the newsroom
mid-morning I hope traffic permitting
and Bethan is on day one of her news
common in social and Emily is on day two
being mobile and Alex Marshall started
yesterday as AE 4vj you and Adam taped
took on responsibility for social as
well as snapchat so there's some staff
changes reminder on clarity we've got a
bit of Brixton news today with Island so
let's make sure that we explain and copy
the backstop and I call 50 withdrawal
agreement and all that sort your bearing
Connor we got the jagged explain of it
thank you
and then for those who weren't around
yesterday we had a bit good Alan had a
bit of good news and we hit the 1
million subscribers mark on youtube so
please take a look at our content on
there I think the ones to call out
especially at the moment Charlie's
brilliant asexual asexuality piece I
look at that and if you liked it share
it and Hannah's done a nice piece on
vegans doing vegan new area
let's set that right anywhere it's also
a good yeah you need to talk up there's
a great playlist of Stein it's very best
of does it still know those snaps what's
at the top yeah I think Mexico okay the
story yesterday was the salah' playing
discovery again I'm pulling out a
Guernsey today but obviously if you see
anything on any rivals or any social
media plug it to the home desk because
it's doing rather well for us so we need
to keep cross up and what are over to
you okay I'll start with Sally keep it
give it give it on racing sulla and then
bricks it
Theresa May it's going to Northern
Ireland today actually make a speech at
twelve o'clock we're gonna kick off a
live look ahead of that it might go for
all by an hour and then we'll see what
lines come out of it there's a few kind
of comings and goings in number ten
before she heads off to it Northern
Ireland as well cabinet meeting half
nine she's also meeting is working to
discuss with the EU and also we've kind
of kicked off with a story on what
Merkel said last night some fairly
positive things about our exes so our
Milbank team Aubry Allegretti
it will be across most of that with some
support from here so oh really the blog
opening will almost certainly do and you
know who's gonna do snap analysis yet or
is that still to be decided now we don't
know we don't know yet though I decided
and then faisal attendant that yeah so
finals puzzles is is in Northern Iowa
okay and he'll follow some analysis at
the end of the day other things this
morning nasty story Paris fire which in
a nice part of Paris killed eight people
number of people killed might go up and
we've got good bit of video on that
which is on the app already and sorry oh
yeah any slightly it looks like it's
arson at the Paris police have arrested
a woman so we'll just keep an eye on
that but even if you just keep her keep
an eye on that what's going on with that
there's a few other bits and pieces I'll
ice stuff about Alex Crawford
interviewing to UK doctors and a
pharmacist are still doing very well so
we'll just keep that keep that up for a
bit
Venezuela keeping an eye on that story's
been doing quite well for us as well
there'd be some development last night
with lots of Latin American countries
kind of urging Maduro to let some film
with that because we have the interview
with Maduro and now we've had the yeah
South American countries saying that
they want the military to side with the
opposition so we've updated the copy
okay push the chunk goes too far down
okay okay can you take another look at
secret secret joint intro to work yeah
yeah been explained about why the
military stood on his side like is it
because they get paid a lot of money so
all we had we had the Air Force so we've
got Dom everything they're doing lives
on it today so we should get Don to pile
up analysis yeah because you know
without the military on side he's
basically you know he's not gonna be
posting it anymore
again and it's already started but
there's not enough time okay well you
gonna watch
Pope good pictures mass in UAE big it's
gotta be so I think we'll
Jochen Connecticut Tennessee doing a bit
of that weird writing that we've written
a story you're still writing Emily on
carers hundreds of people quitting their
jobs to look after loved ones you're
almost done with that are you so we're
doing that a couple of other things
we're putting together a piece which
Amanda Walker filed last night yeah
divided United States which is kind of
on this is yes the update to the
original interactive can why is America
so polarized and she's felt quite a good
analysis felt about that and
okay can we protect that well because it
will do is it do your job previewing
Union it's a great paper to do it yeah
I'm missing the whole student the
keeping an eye on that Libby Squires
appears making repeat last night's okay
where our desks are not keeping a big
close eye on that a few other bits and
bobs on our TV channel we're going to
have the spitting image if you will
spitting image of Margaret Thatcher
touches on an AOP today so the spitting
image of the old video yeah yes so those
things were washing and Charles and
Camilla in court today it's the Supreme
Court's tenth anniversary so another 20
years see with Sky News so chocolate
covalent code that might be finance
Punjab Denmark there's may be sitting on
as a yeah Supreme Court judges benches
are saying the audio of the limits oh
yeah and also I've mentioned and iam
recent story which is we've got some
audio glitch with the version of a now
on TV that you could solve see that's
where with the second I'm doing another
version thanks man
so that can we make sure we give a good
show oh yeah good point but a couple of
other cases including how to garden
trial of the man known as pestle which
we're keeping a close eye on state of
the union of mentioned let's not make
for you doing but that's gonna be able
to not in for us about two o'clock in
the morning our time yeah there's that
I think yeah I've got a couple of things
on my list but okay let's go it out so
we go to Jim oh hi yeah let's go Jenna
and then we'll go to the artist formerly
known as Alex Martin show this and just
before show biz I don't know if you've
seen this Adam Parker just sent an email
from Staffordshire please saying you've
seen them I hope so yeah boy is it for
children have died in a house fire for
children
Colin do only oversee the push
all right so Gemma showbiz so Angelina
Jolie go to Bangladesh - yes oh yeah can
we put that top actually yes put that
top new Tommy
thank you
Angelina Jolie I'm just going to find a
- what's in your Hindi oh there's some
pictures of C not Paul McCartney has got
a gold Blue Peter bad witches got beaten
up yeah we're doing what for services to
music there Peter Jackson got one last
year I think they saw the fairly new ish
thing I'm not sure and then seal look
out for any Liam Neeson Liam Neeson yes
unknown Rd everything yeah yeah
and then another this isn't an any story
and I haven't rather put it I haven't
actually seen this anywhere I've just
seen well just seeing it on Twitter I
haven't had a look to see if anyone who
reported on it but it's quite an unusual
one this let me find out on Twitter a
woman who had a brain tumor
she's tweeted saying I sent my brain
tumor to Antarctica and this is now my
favorite photo of all time because this
woman just a woman here and Arielle
Waldman it he presses a NASA adviser on
Twitter
yeah took her took it to Antarctica and
they're taking this kind of the world
actual brain tumors
like a job
okay go send me that link okay
I mean adjusting really sort of us
extraordinaire so many levels and the
pictures yeah okay to be on the list
okay so dressed for the job that you
want just during that discussion that
historic mentioned that has been face
fire fatalities and then was mentioned
what's known as a push notification get
your mobile for now and just have a
close to hand in the next few seconds
what you get is that notification sent
straight to your phone we tend to do
this only with really significant bits
of news or you don't have a set piece of
ends it's not something we try and
certainly get rather annoyed if your
formal buzzing all day long but let's
just see we can just have a little
listen in them and see if we're getting
close to the point of it being said
I don't know you'll just turn so quickly
that we can operate here literally and
that little you are watching their new
story drops and you still we find a bit
of information I think was from one of
the wire services decisions taken
together there as soon as possible and
that little link will take you to Horton
picture the website will soon there'll
be more information and just had a
question from Emma and asking just how
many how many meetings that are that
take place through the day there are
quite a few you might have heard a
little bit of a giggle from colleagues
in this alternative gallery hear story
meetings essentially half past seven
half past nine and three o'clock
planning meetings looking forward at
coverage late in the day and and those
take place around a quarter past ten
half past the quantified classified and
and the digital huddle that you've seen
this on this kind of mobile only get
together that's a quarter past eight and
a half past two so plenty meetings that
take place through the day I mean in
general back in my days as a reporter we
weren't really welcomed with open arms
into those morning meetings because in
essence that's where some of your
colleagues talk about how you did the
day before and whether or not you were
going to get a decent story that day so
of course I made a point of showing up
from time to time that leads to one of
the characters that you've seen on
screen there Paul Harrison former royal
correspondent currently you see that
Simon is editor he can do a remarkable
impersonation of our head of news John
Riley you will be speaking to a little
bit later on today and he has used it on
five separate occasions to play tricks
on me we might be getting everyone back
to the porn site on Neal hunter
there is one of our to subscribe but in
that position I suspect you'll be the
technical don't know in factories and
he's directing the show Mike Kumar at
the bottom left there we're in the
middle of an interview so you often
don't hear very much chance in the
transmission then as you can see on the
screen and screen there that's them
running the bumper as we call it a
little bit of advertising that takes us
into the weather with nothing that is
going on in the beyond in the VR screen
the video of studio six
as you can see Sarah Jane still talking
to the concert to the guests that we've
had in the studio action basically it is
just easier for our practical points of
view to keep your guests sitting down
before you get live in the studio
otherwise they have a an alarming
tendency to walk in front cameras which
galleries particularly directors don't
know
6 5 4 3 2 1 and take as TX now we're on
a bumper and a break thanks now minify
thing and in a microcosm that is what
goes on in the gallery from day to day
we have at times that we're supposed to
try and hit the brakes that often
doesn't happen because of news or items
over running but timing is everything
using dropping your baby that's why the
big breaking event takes place or this
big live event that takes place and we
want to get to but unfortunately on the
commercial break we will crash into it
the pants a tagine was up to their check
one of our many social media channels
for people of a certain age is Giorgio
Moroder
I've just realized you get Giorgio
Moroder dinner the day that I'm not
working on sunrise fantastic
it'll be a man Alice will watch George
or mother to leave this studio let's
return to Ashish Josh you know where do
you know Ashish that looks like a doctor
looks like a very relaxing cafe area so
it is a race over haven't seen they're
deciding what stories are going to go to
air how they're going to be treated and
what correspondence were attached those
stories are in Tunis laughing many there
was
we've got that right okay so that's
presumably the bit that has been legal
to me go out and we will stick with that
and that's enough that John wants go to
Quinn's there okay there is a possible
story we will cover few I think four or
five pedophile cleanses erected in Leeds
overnight the forced attention
what's imprisonment mark why it's going
to look at that to done a big piece on
it last year that we can use better piss
off we will see where that goes whether
or not we will speak to him and then yes
is going to look after all of this what
we might do is have so she she ain't
hating on looking after the war Channel
when it's on there when either of them
Antoinette we might get them to come and
talk to you and explain exactly what's
going on there are also a couple of
pieces running
newspaper industry and how it hasn't
translated the dude you know trust me
what to do with a seven o'clock
especially last night
yeah okay they're a couple of nice
pieces that's not a running last night
that we will carry on running one is the
SS prisoners that it's awkward piece oh
yeah yeah I'm written to Irish nationals
who claim to be innocent and want help
from their government and there is
George Michael Mitchell spoken to us so
George Mitchell interview about the Good
Friday Agreement other bits and pieces
we are looking at ATM billions being
bought out ministration probably just
the NIV unless week gets there I suppose
we could do anything
Ashley but not Ashley Ashley has lost
his bed cricketing up at some point and
then Robin trial gets underway to the
prosecution outrun their case yes there
we might hear from the defense today
nothing brother
not wanting brunt and that's Adele
burning grunters around today alcohol
use miss you stats out at half past nine
we will just have a look and see whether
they precious still up Bob Dorough so
we'll just keep that going uh blink like
woman can do if you set turns and the
others through cut like this the care is
the one in seven carers having to either
take time off work or expend ton of work
will just give up their jobs completely
I sort of calls for workplaces to be a
bit more honest
it is my good heart who came in about
two months ago which drove the road the
road to somewhere the road somewhere
he's very good on me paying my Paris
that there's a squid army of unpaid
carers for my child care and elder care
policy exchange okay we have a State of
the Union disco set up a hot 11 that we
might spend until tomorrow until after
the event
okay let's see how we do tons because
there's a lot of long BTS and we just
had John Barnes added to the rundown pod
eleven o'clock and so let's see how is
that time this I mean if we get better
good heart
we could start him in as a single guest
instead about this thing and there is a
big news to scope at half and 12 as well
lady has discovered a vars
in her attic and it's been sold for
600,000 pounds needless to say it's come
through a relation who was given it by
somebody in China who had a link to a
Chinese emperor okay I believe the lady
who had it doesn't want to be named but
it was in the UK and it's right
hopefully some people come back try
again
fight because I think the arsenew were
interested as well so quickly when the
philanthropist the physical yes one
hundred million quid all right he's got
a billion invested a lot of money to
give away they have put in going through
Cambridge I think and through his
yeah talk to Adam and call it and
calling you're about to go on air are
you happy with the way the news is
shaping up come some breaking news
stories you've got the fire to deal with
two fires yeah I mean as always we sit
there in the 7:30 meeting you get an
agenda and look at your rundown thing
that's pretty much gonna fill it and
then throughout the day within an hour
or so I mean it sounds like for the
tragic story and you're just getting
details spigot now so yeah got a course
one on the way there Colin as an anchor
how much of an input do you have into
these edits or meetings you just given
the stories and you go off and prepare
yourself for decisions how you feeling
heads with you revved up it's a quiet
news day it's a patchy news today but
yeah I mean you have certain hobby
horses
one of mine you know some suggest the
guests who may come true for us or not
you can shape it into a good degree yeah
absolutely have to be because it's
changing all the time what you know
don't even spend two hours preparing put
into your a story that they're technical
reasons doesn't happen that's quite a
pitch to see happen you know tense on a
pin a little bit you could be quite
flexible and quite fleet-footed yeah for
sure
yeah and Adam are you happy with what's
being given to you today or do you
always go back and say sorry I just
can't go for this I need more reporters
I need more people well I mean there's
always a resources issue I mean most the
time we've got people who can get to
where they need to be I don't think it
looks like there's gonna be an issue
today and you know we will always try to
make sure that everything fits in the
time that we're given location or one
new stress manifested truth-telling
issues that normally there's one little
gallows humor which you ever be
surprised to know we excised from that
meeting I thought I was quite at a
meeting quite surprised but hey look
good luck we'll be speaking to you as
you prepare to go on air and while
you're on air as well then Adam good
luck with your news gathering in your
programming your outputs today we are
going to go back into the newsroom in a
little while to talk to the head of Sky
News John Riley that should be an
interesting interview
one for you to mind your P's and Q's on
definitely a sham or I'll slip back into
the newsroom a number of meetings of
course taking place across the across
the organization as much as anything
else just to make sure that we're all
singing from the same hymn sheet that we
know the stories that we want to hit but
as you've also hurts and you probably
also seem as we've moved through those
at meetings there has already been an
evolution to the news stories have
cropped up that worm their own Saturday
night at half-past seven there are all
now being busily added to rundown zaire
correspondents who weren't assigned to
stories have already are all ready to
get into the cars and a little later on
in fact they're on Sky News wrong will
be falling around Sally what good a
story from drop from start to finish
we're entering into the little a skin of
20 minutes of sunrise I mean that is a
shift and a half for people that work on
that program I mean I wake up at around
about half past two and I'm generally
office 1/2 minus 3 at the team who've
been in at before midnight and that
doesn't mean that I always get taken off
ball certainly we always meet and we
fight we'll be showing you a little bit
over afterwards a little debrief huddle
in the same place identity was just
meeting at jazz college sure given we'll
just mention Colin I mean there is a man
who's I mean the consummate presenter is
intelligently smart his eloquent and
unflappable which I have to say I think
is probably the quality that youth most
to do the job that he does he was
formerly of course a a correspondent a
reporter out in the field what is a
youth correspondent for a girl fixed any
period of time and that does play into
what have to have been a reporter to be
a presenter but sometimes it helps
my buddy there who's editing on the home
desk once again final preparations are
being made as we move from this building
down to Westminster for all-out politics
it's been a a huge priority of course in
the lead-up to that 2016 referendum and
in the aftermath that we we give as much
resources we can and to our politics
programs are and indeed the politics
department you can just see over the
camera there
Adam Bolton our editor at large that
basically prepping for the show he also
generally tends to have a little quick
chat with sailor Jean on Sunrise little
throw ahead as we call it a little tease
to the program not sure if that's
happening today sometimes it gets
dropped
this is the man who'll be earning
earning and the next your frog name is
obvious whistling and my son locked in
and variety of reasons that I won't bore
you with and we use a different gallery
for the program from Westminster than
the gallery that we are currently using
for sunrise so there's a bit of
technical jiggery-pokery that needs to
take place I can a few seats that need
to be moved to keep your questions
coming in at Chris Houston in fact I
know as an email then asking how do you
do with reading the autocross you've got
all those voices in media do you want
that for a percentage point of view
enough can speak for everyone that part
of it is it is not difficult when you're
reading from a script it's quite easy to
compartmentalize one part of your brain
to deal with the stuff that you're
reading and saying out loud and the
other part of your brain to listening to
the voices the voices in your ear as a
producer in the gallery I just mentioned
it does rather depend on the director
that you have there there's some
directors speak more some directors
speak less a happy medium is always best
[Music]
and Ashish is there in the newsroom once
again and Ashish whether you know I
think you were mentioning you're going
to be talking to our native News John
well they've been head of news since
when 2006 John Riley took over as a head
of Sky News he's been here much longer
than that of course an even longer in in
television look this is the newsroom
it's quite quiet at the moment
everyone's busy after their morning
meetings deciding what they have to do
and on this side of the newsroom just
give you a sense of the geography
looking out across up all of this in
this office first thing you notice no
walls no doors this is John Riley behind
his desk hard at work good morning John
all right good morning how are you I'm
very good good yeah look one of the
first things that has to be asked is
when you announced this idea of Sky News
war it was met with in agility it was
just why on earth would you let so many
cameras into a working news environment
why are you doing this job
we decided today to let the cameras in
behind the scenes in our control rooms
and our meeting rooms in the news room
to talk to people and see how we work
because I feel very strongly that it's
important that news organizations are
transparent about the decisions they
take I'm keen that we demonstrate that
we're a group of people who come to work
non-stop 24/7 to try and make stories
that are significant and relevant to our
audiences without any particular agenda
our aim is to offer and produce
world-class independent news I think
it's good to try and knock down the
barriers I also think that I hope in a
very small way what we're doing today
will encourage young men women from all
sections of your society to want to work
in television whether it's as a camera
operator a sound recordist as a floor
manager on-air or someone who makes
decisions behind the scenes to see that
actually anyone could work in television
and it's not
preserve of a privileged elite that's
one of the things before we talk about
the past in the press when you look out
across your news them it's a very
diverse newsroom and that that's one of
the things you're very keen on on
engaging with this is people from not
the traditional backgrounds who work in
television news but trying to get other
people interested in what we do you know
the people here responsible for the
recruitment of both technical teams and
journalists and on-air staff have gone
out of their way the last five six years
to try and encourage people who wouldn't
naturally think of a career in
television to think about it because
great fun I mean like all jobs it has
its ups and downs but it's great fun and
you get to work on some really exciting
projects both in front of the camera and
behind the camera and remember as well
Sky News is now a multi-product news
organization so there's opportunity and
radio and opportunities of course in the
digital journalism you were talking
about transparency I guess as the head
of Sky News that's one of your biggest
challenges is to restore trust in
journalism and restore trust in media
not just in Sky News but media in German
take it shoe bit with your word with
store I mean I've been lucky enough to
work too on the BBC nine o'clock news as
it was then 30 years ago on the news at
10:00 in the days of Trevor McDonald and
even Alastair Burnett and here for a
very long time
I think broadcast news has a very strong
track record of offering accurate news
and current affairs so I think this
issue of restoring trust
I think the mainstream broadcasters have
a very strong record of offering the
British public and international
audiences in our case accurate impartial
news training it's a question of
restoration how do you convince people
but Sky News are the news organizations
in this country are to be trust because
we've seen in
Oh an American what's happening there
fake news we didn't even talk about that
news 5 years ago suddenly it's why
everyone's lives that's not one of your
biggest challenges it's a challenge but
it's always a challenge to ensure that
said earlier I guess that we are really
rigorous in our journalism and I don't
think you know some organizations have
hard fact checkers and all that
I think it's about employing men and
women who are very focused on pursuing
the truth very focused and getting the
facts right accurate news is about
checking information and getting the
facts right and if you're not sure about
something don't broadcast it don't
publish it get the facts right and it
may take a while to confirm a story or
if you're not sure about the entire
validity of a story as it's developing
tell your audiences what you do know and
your hunt potential and what you're not
entirely sure about be straight and
honest and transparent with them sure I
suppose so much has changed while you've
been a journalist but sky has always
been one of those organizations with a
reputation for being first and fast has
that changed with the advent of social
media is that still our wears on d'etre
do we still pay more attention to
breaking news because that's what the
public to then to Sky News for or can we
be Twitter can we beat the other social
media oh we can beat that breaking news
we can be beaten by being right so on
Saturday for instance our city editor
mark Kleiman
wrote the story that his'n was no longer
going to carry on with the production of
its new model of car in Sunderland a big
story with very significant
repercussions for the northeast of
England and Beyond Sky News I guess has
changed a little bit it's no longer just
about straps across the bottom of the
screen we employ a number of specialists
a political team of Foreign Affairs team
we have a lot of viewers around the
in in business and economics I've
mentioned and an in science and
technology and we expect them to find
out what's going on and reveal stories
come up with original distinct
journalism so sky is still about big
coverage or big breaking news events
terrible things like the Grenville fire
but you were involved in that morning
it's also about offering original
distinct journalism and I think one can
outdo the likes of Twitter all right I'm
running out and there's so many
questions at once to asking first of all
in your years at Sky News your top three
stories that you've been involved in um
in Sky News yes I like big stories with
consequences so September the 11th 2001
9/11 was a massive story big story with
very significant geopolitical
consequences well after the date itself
that was a big deal for me in for Sky
I like the campaign's that Sky News has
run we led the charge on the election
for TV election debates in 2009 2010
trying to be more transparent with court
coverage and get the cameras into courts
with the other broadcasters and of
course our campaign on single-use
plastic
journalism can be a force for good the
final thing I stories I like bizarre
stories and I wasn't the boss it's a
long time ago 15 years ago we just story
about a horse on a farm in
Northamptonshire and it loved playing
football and we sent a team off to cover
it and we had this horse dribbling the
ball live and I think that's what
television should really sort of revel
in you know the big and the bizarre
great I've been getting lots of
questions from our viewers you've
answered most those I have been getting
viewers from my colleagues people who
work under me and the one question they
want to know just say yes or no answer
if you would do you watch Sky News
output 24 hours day not quite because
they feel like you do sometimes Thank
You Jon Riley
the head of Sky News giving us an
insight into what it's like and is
highly pressurized well leaving this
team of journalists 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year
ashes thanks a teacher is pretty easy to
be quite cynical but hopefully you're
getting an impression that from the very
top literally from the top of the
organization die we enjoy our work here
at Sky News wood enthusiastic about it
what what excited about it and there are
a myriad of ways in which if you are
getting slightly excited about this you
can make your way into journalism would
be a radio television broadcast in
general or print I mean I had a pretty
securities route in turn s in SIA I was
working as a freelancer on what's known
as the contracts desk in the newsroom it
was an admin position no editorial no
and no chance of appearing on television
the lady who ran that desk Paulina
mentioned to the then head of input guy
called Simon call that do you know what
this new guy likes his politics I was
called in for an interview for a
permanent job on the contracts desk the
next day for milk said you haven't got
it
but sent me down to Westminster
Westminster butyl on a three-month
contract as an what was known as a news
assistant and around about six months
after that maybe nine months sort of
push I did my first shift as a political
reporter you can in television if you
are enthusiastic enough and indeed if
you've got an organization like Sky with
people like John Reilly Peter Lorre out
of the Bolton
Jonathan leave you behind you trying to
get you enthusiastic and trying to get
you and you can end up presenting the
Sky News wrong although politics all-out
politics is just coming off at the in a
few minutes time so let's see how we
move out from the gallery that you're
watching on your screen to the one next
door and take us into the program at
proper already less cold - and that vein
is going to be moving eastwards through
today with heavy 20 times across Ireland
Northern Ireland Scotland Wales and
Northern or western parts of England
especially East Midlands and central
southern eastern England will become
cloudy
three on the bumper thanks nuts make an
ass
stand by we go we are off PCR 22 thank
you very much thanks Gary much Cheers
22 to th just let you know we're in
Gallery 22 please not to count to us
thank you 242 the ident now just let you
know we're in 22 now for next two hours
thank you and there are food on the
intro yeah hey the cam cams
yeah welcome to news with some breaking
news this hour
bonden there in the Adam you seen also Q
moves there yeah John is Adam the
producer in the sky he's got Rahimi all
right thank you very much for joining us
what papi said about four five minutes
away from come to you that all right
just queuing up making sure that the
next guest the outside sources right
here we go standing by sort of 45
sometimes in large their connectivity of
course all the districts under 14 like
in time sorry let's go ahead five
seconds four three two
why beautiful thank you wipe nice five
notice the game that a lot of
communication not just amongst the staff
from the gallery the producing the
director tend to talk to each other all
the way through the program when they
don't talk to each other that's when
programs can go wrong but it's also
speaking to the staff outside as a way
making sure that as things are being
stated that the stories are moving the
scripts are changing practically in real
time as new bits of vision and audio get
either secured by our camera crews or
reporters or fed to us by agencies
getting those onto the programmers as
soon as possible as well during the
transition period to work on a deal but
if we get the end of that transition and
no agreement then then we use that time
to go work whatever Monica you want to
use and now currently working they
worked yesterday they met yesterday that
feverishly working now well it's our
item in the gallery we we're gonna play
out a minute 45 package on the parents
fire and then we will come to you it's a
straight life isn't that younger
industry zippy Squire with Sally
Lockwood moved I moved on bonds up a
little bit above coffee space because is
there waiting bees happy to wait let's
take you away from Kelly 21 fact to
Milbank as it's commonly known but
essentially there's our studios in the
heart of Westminster this the newsroom
the desk on the wrong desk on the right
hand side is essentially well was where
you see the candidate the political
editor the head of political news this
is shot from the the end of the newsroom
Adam Bolton despite the fact he came off
here 10 minutes ago
still waiting there will be speaking to
him in a minute or twos time
but it's difficult to it's difficult to
kind of it's difficult to exaggerate
just how much of an exciting place it
can be Westminster know in politics many
people say it's called a dry subject of
late
surely that isn't the case it's the
place to be where the stories are moving
on and developing so let's say turn our
attention once again to end Brady who
will be joining us
take us through well give us a little
bit of a tour Westminster let us know a
little bit more about what's going on
there look another gallery there's Endor
I know we're inside the gallery here
this is all the technical stuff happens
behind the scenes which makes all our
presenters and correspondents look good
I'm not going to touch any of these
buttons because genuinely I haven't got
a clue what they do Gareth our technical
supervisor here tells me that these
control the camera shutters so I'm gonna
leave them well alone and we're gonna go
for a little walk now so we are in
Milbank this is the building in
Westminster where all of the political
correspondents and news channels are
based and where the politicians come and
they do their interviews and they will
go from Sky News that will do an
interview here that will go elsewhere
that will go on all the news channels
and then they will zip back across the
road to Parliament to whatever
parliamentary business they are doing
and I have here he has finished all our
politics we're gonna turn the tables on
them mr. Adam Bolton great to see you on
Sky News Raw Adam talked me through your
typical day day I mean when we started
30 years ago for example and Jonathan
Skerritt behind the camera was there we
didn't even have a camera crew assigned
regularly to Westminster that we had an
office we're actually the first people
to have an office but we had me and two
correspondents one producer and a
freelance crew which we hired in as
needed
what we could do and we were the first
people to do that was broadcast live at
any time and we had correspondents based
here like in a foreign Bureau who never
had to go back to the headquarters so in
that sense we really changed the way
political broadcasting was done in that
country in this country and we've moved
on in that way so you know there isn't a
typical day because you don't know
what's going to be happening in
politics certainly as an interview and a
presenter what you want is the
unexpected I mean I I feel very unhappy
if I do a program and I think I have
learned anything over those two hours or
three hours because then that means the
public haven't happened so what you want
is is news that's what's called news you
want to hear something new so this
business has changed so much
year-on-year you were here on day one
our cameraman Jonathan Skerritt he was
here on day one people like me have just
perished within halfway through but you
know the change of pace must be
extraordinary yeah I mean it really has
changed because I mean back when we
started it was actually my second
startup I done startup with a company
called tvam so I knew you had to get
everything in your contract not just you
know for yourself but the fact that you
would have a guaranteed number of phone
lines that you'd have a fax machine
remember them of course the internet
didn't exist so for many years we were
actually doing breaking news first with
the news all the time and then as mobile
phones have come online as the internet
happened most people probably get their
first glimmer of a news story if they're
following it on the internet so we have
to make sure that we can be first and
accurate and comprehensive in what we do
but I mean again the difference of Sky
News 24-hour news is as you know ender
we often report stories when we don't
have the full picture what we have to do
is to gather the information and to tell
our audience what we know and what we
don't know and gradually build it up on
there as we broadcast which of course is
different from doing a news bulletin how
has social media changed what you did
exchanged a lot I mean I've just been
looking at my sort of daily greetings
and you know they're rude
another joke guest on Sky News comes on
about how democracy becomes a
dictatorship a delusional arrogant
know-it-all that's that's about a guest
I mean there is nastiness in the air
which when you think yeah it is new it's
come with the internet it's come it's
come with with Twitter and you know it's
often pretty sad people actually who
just want to criticize everything you do
you know
why didn't you ask this question or even
if you didn't ask it you didn't ask it
early enough in the interview so yeah I
mean it's more unpleasant doing this job
than it used to be it used to be a joy
frankly to go out and have a front seat
on history now you have to stay in touch
but you get this sort of daily buckets
of crap if you reply to people I do I
don't get into Jules on line but I do
retweet what they say and correct them I
mean you know for example we have some
of the other day saying oh that's just
what I expect that guest to say typical
German well I pointed out actually there
he was from Finland so I you know I will
correct people when they get things
wrong but I don't want to get into spats
with people because partly that's you
know what turns them on but you know it
keeps us on our toes but it does mean
that we have to do exactly what I was
talking to you about which is to make
sure that we are being as accurate as
precise as fair as we possibly can be in
our questioning where we stand right now
with the political situation brigs it is
is this the biggest rolling political
story you've been involved in and all
we've seen prime ministerial arrivals
and departures and sackings and what
have you
Gregg's us has been going on forever
it's a massive story and it's different
and the reason why it's different and
really that's what I was talking about
with that guest that people were abusing
is that the political system isn't
really working that in the end we've
operated on a system where we've had two
or three or four parties with a
leadership they've contested the ideas
with each other now what we've got now
is every party certainly the
conservative and labor parties are
absolutely divided amongst themselves
they don't have the answers nobody has a
majority in parliament and it's at a
time when partly thanks to social media
people have less and less confidence in
them so you know it really is a time
when important issues that are gonna
affect all our lives are being decided
in the politicians are just feeling
their way in a darkened room like the
rest of us out of Bolton thanks for your
time all our politics is off air and
Adam is just taking the time to go
through his social media and respond
to people and them will leave you with a
shot of our Milbank newsroom all my
colleagues in there working on their
stories what's coming up next on air and
this is Milbank the beating heart of
political reporting in the UK end of
thank you I've got to say I don't
thought being here since day one of Sky
News that's 30 years of experience Plus
that that he had at tvam under his belt
lots of people will know him simply as a
fantastic political broadcaster I have
to say he's also a genuinely nice guy as
well he's been incredibly helpful to me
at every stage of my career my first day
in Westminster he in the van head of the
unit Peter Lorre took me downstairs for
a coffee told me look if anyone tries to
poach you come and speak to us and we'll
make sure that we hold on to I hadn't
even lifted a pen working at Westminster
let alone appeared on there
unfortunately no one did let's
entender brady never knowingly
starstruck
you got your bearings on about Liam
Neeson
let's take you back to the home - Mike
Bradbury and Paul Harrison there let's
see exactly how the stories have evolved
their call they talking across the desks
into assignments no nuts at the part of
the desk that handles your crew bookings
and indeed hotel bookings were moving
away let's just have a listen see see
what the whole canister are listening it
to the chap you see the talk why do you
scream John Barnes at talking about the
Liam Neeson story Pollock was mentioned
that we might be speaking to the former
Celtic villager a little bit earlier err
on Sky News wrong so you need to have
people monitoring that what's going on
it is it is very easy when you've got 24
hours to fill and lots and lots of
interviews I think it's 700-800 into
every month sometimes news lines we call
them can slip through the net so
monitoring and turning that material
around as we talk at all important so
good we've got such a big set of locks
as Paul Harris and hers and listening
my Katie Spencer standing there Katie
you're gonna be speaking to another one
of our colleagues here this time my boss
so be nice please yes don't go
commenting on the size of my lugs slowly
um so before we go and speak to
Christina who is all of our bosses I
just thought I'd walk you past the
daytime team what are we on it's coming
up to 18 minutes past 11:00 so you've
got basically half of the day time team
working on the output that's happening
at the moment but also we're building a
run down at the moment only for the 12
doesn't stop it's constant that's the
joy of being a rolling news channel so
what we're going to do while they're
doing that yourself it looks kinda being
a negative little bit risky challenging
the status quo and this seemed a perfect
way of celebrating our 30 years there's
been a lot of nervousness about being on
back pay on television you're used to it
I'm not I spent many years keeping away
from the cameras but interesting someone
just came up to me about five minutes
ago won't name him but he came up to me
he said I was really worried about this
I was really worried I nearly didn't do
it why I discussed it with my wife and
actually I'm really glad our day because
it's really good we show me what's going
on and with always saying there's only a
little bit of jeopardy and you know you
hope you will behave but I think it's
been a so far it seems have been a
pretty positive thing
I hope you learn what enjoy watching it
yeah I mean 30 years of sky you've been
here for a couple well yeah it's two
actually is I guess having projects like
this is that what sort of attracted you
that's coming
absolutely I'm I was at the other place
ITN for battery in two years and the
thing that brought me over here was the
fact that at Sky News we've got a TV
platform we've got a mobile app we've
got a website we do the radio for all
the radio stations we've been debating
stations Britain we've got fantastic
phone rings on all the social media
platforms we can make news you can make
documentaries if you come to Sky News
the world is your oyster you can have a
mad idea like this one and and make it
happen so yeah the reasons I came here
you do do the odd media interview as
well I wanted to say when it whenever I
hear you interviewed pretty much the
first question it is asked it is always
how is it being a sort of female
management while every woman blowin
thing yes rating I mean you're the sort
of the leading woman here has it been
hard getting here no I don't think it's
been hard getting here I think that
despite the fact that I knew them as
reputation this industry but not being
particularly female friendly if I can
manage it then anyone can I'm proud to
say that I have been in journalism for
thirty years and managed to find the
husband okay works and TV as well but I
have two children managed to kind of do
the juggling act and I just think it's
really important that women step up and
get jobs in senior roles in this
business not just in TV but in
newspapers right across the media
because 50% audiences female I think is
really important though there's a it's
only actually come more senior I realize
how important is to make sure that
female voices are heard every single
liberal organization we just could just
move beyond things yeah it's in actual
fact across all businesses not just
media but across all businesses
companies that have boards with a
balance of men and women actually make
more money
that simple can we ask you about your
role the cell director of contents yeah
what what does that involve on it it's
only tell me it can involve everything
so in theory so my job actually knew my
title is search of content the sky news
so I'm in charge of the production
starting the meeting today on radio on
TV and online documentaries the pledge
you know a huge amount of amount outputs
I work very closely toward the levy
who's the director of news gathering and
John Riley is the sort of senior
leadership my day can be what it's
hugely buried so I'll go to editorial
meetings we'll talk about some of the
stories there's various stories I've got
real passion for but I think you know
again my background and me being a woman
and a wife and a mom gives me a
perspective on some stories that others
wouldn't necessarily have but I can be
involved in all sorts of things like to
think this image is okay to go out can
we say this should we be doing this
story I've got something in my team
who's not working the way they should do
someone's got to kind of operation these
cover them just everything it is quite
challenging when you need to a private
conversation with somebody but I didn't
want to get locked in a stairwell
can you sense when something is
happening to you if there are sort of
noise that is made from the news not
noise it's a physical thing is that
actually when I was in ice beneath
editor and the guy who is sort of my
boss and my mentor always told me when a
big stories happening stand up yeah and
so when the big SOI breaks people tend
to stand up it looks like you're in
control your authority problem is now
who is standing desks if you're standing
up in the time but you can definitely
know when there's a buzz you couldn't
there's always a once the noise level
goes up but there's an atmosphere it's
hard putting on it you know it don't you
buzz isn't it
thank you Christina for talking to us we
will leave
yes we'll just have one more wander back
to the daytime outfit TV shall we will
see what they're working on where
they're up to at the moment what time
are we at now then 1124 so yes what's
happening on the live channel at the
moment we've got any guests coming up
Katie thanks very much as you can see
we're putting at pretty much everyone
who doesn't generally appear on here not
just on air but under pressure as well
who's coming up next on the channel a
quick check we don't know everything
seemed pretty fluid and so once again
let's kind of move our way around the
newsroom and see if we can dip into a
few conversations poorhouse and again on
the forum Mike Bradbury on the phone now
it's rare to see either of them not only
for over to the foreign desk and again
of course events in the Paris of him
that's something that we've been
following there today
the whole design of the newsroom was
initially set up to try and encourage
conversations between the different
disparate parts of skying years that a
good occasion the tendency with other
news organizations to view digital as a
separate operation television as an
operation raid the ORS an operation a
helix Kony's we've been trying to bring
everything together there partly because
of course you want to maximize the
output that you can get from the
resources that you have but also because
the core qualities at the heart of
everything that we do in terms of you
know the way that we research your
stories the way that we stand there mark
time you that shouldn't differ from
platform to platform the way in which we
tell the story certainly does but at the
core of it whether or not it is true the
way in which we analyze the way in which
we explain the news that should be
pretty much it standard across
jessica's TVs just looking down at
Heights the computer we've used a
variety of computer systems open media
is one that we use in it sir we get
there and Francesca's putting together
the rundown for the for the afternoon
program rundown is probably something
that needs a little bit of explanation
literally if you can imagine our list of
let's just say five stories ranked in
order of importance that is the bare
bones of what a rundown is but more than
that because we move operate on
something of an automated system these
days we literally schedule events
happening in a rundown there's that new
hunter how the chat the picture you can
see there looks like it's cording as we
see at the run bone for the next are
working very very hard indeed one of the
biggest rules in any news organization
Katie's of course looking ahead planning
for well not just what happens in the
next 12 24 hours but you know what can
happen three six twelve months down the
line yeah an incredibly important role
really because we can't just be reacting
all the time Rachel Lynde she were our
planning editor aren't you Rachel and so
we're all what we've seen from the live
feed everyone like on the general sort
of daytime output what your team here
doing what days are you looking at well
we're basically anything from tomorrow
right up to events even kind of six
months in advance so well just seem the
the home desk reacting to stories like
this is happening let's go go go we we
kind of make news and we decide what's
gonna be happening and we're a bit more
proactive so Georgia who's sitting
that's me looking specifically at
tomorrow
where we've done all at the stage of
deciding what stories you want to do you
know you can't just send someone to
think about all sorts of things that how
did it get there who didn't speak to you
once they're there I'll be even not
allowed to be there so permissions to
get to all sorts of places
so I look generally the week ahead maybe
look further afield and that's--and
anything up to you know six months in
advance as d-day anniversary coming up
so presumably there's a number of ways
that you can get stories then how do you
how do you find out about what's going
on there's a loads of different ways so
sometimes this is probably the least
usually people just tell us we make sure
that what they're saying is actually a
story but I think the most common way we
get stories is from our reporters
correspondents having contacts in the
field building up relationships with
people so they tell them things so they
whistle blow and all we do our own
research we do Freedom of Information
requests we go into deep research about
the subject that we think is interesting
we find out if there are untruths there
so that's a lot of time that's all we
get stories and sometimes you know
people want to tell us their story and I
say people governments charity so we get
things called press releases
you know honestly most of them are
rubbish and whilst they think it's a
story that's part of our different
planning to go
I don't you've got an act to guide this
isn't a story and we're not going to put
our resource into it every now and again
there is something which we do think
it's a story perhaps the government are
putting a huge amount of cash into a
children's service we think drop that is
genuine that's a lot of
money and it's gonna improve a lot of
people's lives in which case we will do
it before I leave explain to us we've
got specialist desk over here and family
there they're a part of your team they
are yep a she-devil app so I'm in a cool
leather jacket with a perhaps easy he
runs the head specialist Oh optimal
specialists it in Milbank just because
it tends to be the central London is an
easy place to get to lots of dead
contact that they're generating original
story very much so very much so and
Sarah Dawkins over there she's so she's
on another big area well the the home
news basis here as you as you know the
the senior news editor
his Paul Harrison and his deputy of the
moment is my cranberry yeah I sit there
so I I sit in front of between planning
you just spoke to Rachel can you
associate between them and the big news
desert the news nests is much more of an
operational on the day what's happening
now and as head of home news is it sort
of you sat there so you're keeping one
ear on what's going on house no yeah
sure but it's a but you know everything
about my job is is about trying to weave
between the management of the editorial
side the news stories and as
particularly the biggest news stories
and also managing the people the team
that as you know and I think in any in
any kind of news and broadcast news or
mobile and online sites the the three
big the three big areas when people ask
me that question as they have over very
many years or where do you get the news
from I think they're if you imagine a
pie chart or three the three different
four big chunks things that you can plan
so plan to news when you just talked to
Rachel a lot about planning although it
didn't
they what he said but obviously people I
said well hadn't planned news when you
can find these because you know you know
events that are coming up and you could
have to work out how you want to go so
we knew that today the Prime Minister
was going to help so we had to have
planned in place to be able to to cover
that especially as our senior Island
correspondent based in Belfast was
actually out the country their time so
we had to we had to work that one out in
parts of Islam our political energy was
not over there we know that there is a
report coming out later today about
about environmental pollution affecting
has been filming a piece about the way
in which children are affected by air
pollution so those are the kind of plans
in other part of the pie chart is
stories and hidden expenses a terrible
fire in or hollingsworth terrible
politics today and another really
terrible fire and snappish in today
we're poor children because nobody could
have planned for these the for these of
them so the future they happen and you
and you go and cover them the same with
you know the recent tragedy about
Emiliana sound of the
the Argentinian footballer who died on
his way from Nam to Cardiff that comes
out of the blue it happens and you have
to send people to college to norms
although actually we didn't immediately
go to North and you have to and you go
to Guernsey so those are things you have
to respond to deploy a camera and the
third bit of the pie chart is original
stories but we ourselves want to pursue
as journalists here are specialists or
political regimes and so I want to
pursue stories that they're finding out
things themselves so the tension always
exists between the planned story the
original journalism and the older day
breaking story that you have to go and
cover so that's why there's so much
juggling by the news desk and why you
need to have one central point of which
you which you curate everything a sort
of non-stop and and that's that that's
the obvious thing about this place is
the TV channel is on the air all of the
time 24 hours a day 365 days a year I
think you work most and as well I mean
best laid plans we've seen the various
sort of neat things today things can
just change within the space and
sometimes you sit in a morning meeting
and discuss three or four stories that
Indian never appeared because something
else much much bigger happens when you
and you only have to do that instead and
of course today the way in which
way in which we didn't find news and
delivered news has changed immeasurably
over the thirty years of which skies
existed I've not been here 30 years 20
years I used to work with BBC and I left
after 11 years of the BBC and I thought
to myself well that was a long time I'll
never work for the same company for that
long again I'm still here enjoying
myself immensely at Sky News I think
yeah I mean I think it's always exciting
to be able to be a journalist I mean I
you know I remember the times when I
send reporters out on stories and they
had some phone in there to ring in from
a from a phone box to tell me how they
were to keep me on the on a news desk in
the loop with how they were getting on
but but now we can you know when I
joined Sky News we have two satellite
trucks so we could with a couple of
exceptions like Downing Street and other
places in Westminster we could only
really be live from two places now we
can be live from almost anywhere we want
anywhere in the world at any time using
using modern technology so it's
increased the amount of stories we can
do to increase the possibilities
it's it's increase the amounts of
occasions where you where you probably
end up having to to juggle things for
the production team in the gallery where
sometimes things that you do never
actually get on thank you
when I stay back to Minogue news
operation center now this is where all
of the line non large material is
brought in Jose seeing Lisa Robson there
it runs knock and just the back that's
Roebuck is one of our engineers who's
been allowed in from a satellite truck
for once we take a bit of a broader
picture you will in essence see it looks
like another gallery all of these inputs
coming in from amongst others the
Reuters TV service apt and The
Associated Press TV service our Bureau
and various parts around the world all
of this material being brought and at
some point if you see pictures somewhere
if you see a report that means their
cameraman and a journalist have been on
that story so let's move away shall we a
little bit from the Sky News sent and
head out into the field and speak to
Sally Lockwood who as you can see
holding a microphone at the back of a
chop salad
take us through the process how do you
get the news on tell
nil I can just about hear you I can also
hear Katie Spencer in my ear still I
think but just to let you know what
we're doing here in the hall today we're
on the story of the missing student
Libby Squire who is a student at the
University of Hull now we're opposite
the University today there's not been a
huge amount of activity of course a
really worrying story so it was a very
serious atmosphere here and we
understand the university is working
closely with the police to do with her
disappearance so we're just waiting for
updates really we've been in touch with
the police this morning we've been to
three different locations to see what
activity there might be in the way of
searches and the like it's very quiet at
the moment so we're just staying across
that and and as with many of these
stories once you've done all you can in
terms of checking out the local area
contacts calling police it is a bit of a
waiting game so today our setting is a
pub car park opposite the university
very warm hosts to earth today we've
been here since around 7 a.m. now for
many of us our home Bureau is Manchester
so that was a two hour drive for me
which meant a 4 a.m. alarm call but of
course as with many early alarm calls I
actually wake up at 3 this is Andy he
said one of the cameras on the job today
and whether you come from Andy I've come
from Weasley I traveled over this
morning
like a two hour drive yet yeah so I got
away this morning we arrived just to
going up to the light in the dark
coming up to light and then we set off
just outside the front here yeah
satellite dish broadcast first two hits
and then we're just setting up for
another headset twelve o'clock now this
four of us here today we will come from
four different locations for different
vehicles and my car I've always got a
bag full of charges passport change of
clothes boots all manner of coats wet
weather gear and all sorts but Andy
definitely smashes my record with kit
don't talk to me about what you have in
the Sat truck here Andy so generally
we've got a camera lighting full-cut
lighting rig in the boots
satellite dish on top of the truck if we
come Lister on this side over here and
we open the side of the gun we've got a
full kit set up I read it comes in
they're ready to go for a lunchtime live
where we're putting out bars at the
moment so they're not transmitted in any
physical pictures no we in here as well
and we pretty much live in here on jobs
yeah we do we live in here with this
boot effectively is our office and our
home sometimes even for 24 hours on
occasions we spend a lot of time editing
and then once we've done that we feed it
over the satellite straight to London
and he goes out on air yeah we do spend
an awful lot of time and here were quite
spoilt having a pub for warmth today
aren't we yeah yes and you should use
your to be so close to a sort of warm I
should probably mention Andy how long
you've been doing it about 22 years now
okay now everywhere we go in the north
of England without fail Andy denill has
a story what's your whole story right
well the last time I was in Hull Paul
Heaton was walking through the town
centre and to me it was a I was a
massive fan of beautiful self so when he
walked past I didn't recognize him at
first I thought I knew him remind
viewers he like Paul Heaton beautiful
self
so abandon the mid-nineties I would
reckon just some fantastic hits they
were by I loved I thought someone I
loved them so much I went to see them
young numerous occasions so to see him
walk through the whole town centre was a
bit of a buzz for me and you've got a
story for every location that's his
whole story now I understand Neil you've
got some questions from viewers yet
certainly just don't obviously you do
you and I were both been out on the road
for a number of years a question that
keeps cropping up is how do you work how
do you manage to work on on stories
which have a bit of emotional heft or on
the stories where there is a degree of
tragedy involved do you approach them in
a different manner do you have to it in
a different manner to be able to to be
able to cope on stories such as that
that's a good question
it's not something
you consciously think about I don't
necessarily anyway I think it's just
instinctively you behave differently on
stories like that because you're very
aware of the seriousness of the nature
of the story the impacts on the people
involved and of course you sense the
atmosphere and soak it up and and very
often you take it home with you as you
I'm sure know Neal it's something that
you can't help but be affected by but
obviously we're here to do a job and you
detach yourself from it to an extent
whereby yes you may be absorbing the
emotions and atmosphere around you but
because we are obviously having to
deliver the news the adrenaline I think
takes over on stories like that what
would you say yeah I have to say I think
I probably agree it's it's in the
aftermath of a story that that perhaps
things begin to catch up with you a
little bit whilst you're immersed in
events you know what I did you know
politics for example a general election
where you don't really understand what's
going on until the very end of it but
last question to you Sally before we
before we leave you and get on because
obviously you do have a job to do today
what's you in terms of the stories that
you've covered not necessarily at Sky
News what's been the highlight for you I
have to admit it was when President
Obama said hello young man
that was my highlight career highlight
oh my goodness and the stories are so
varied aren't they whenever I get put on
the spot and someone asks me that I find
it a really difficult question to answer
but I think probably the most
embarrassing moment for me was when I
was interviewing Simon Cowell and he
turned it into interviewing me which was
rather embarrassing but I think probably
a highlight in terms of most memorable
story was perhaps in the summer last
year when a big team of us were sent out
to Thailand to cover the rescue of those
12 young footballers and their coach who
were trapped in a cave for several weeks
that was something that I don't think I
will necessarily surpass for a long time
in terms of being absorbed in a story
and uncovering something that really
gripped the world you know we were
getting messages from all over the world
viewers we just hooked on that
story willing a good ending and on for
the major part we did manage to
obviously report a very happy ending
which was just obviously a real
privilege Sally thank you very much
indeed adieu give my best to Andy denill
I know he's got stories from every part
of the country he's got plenty of
stories involving nice if he can keep
those to himself that bit that would be
brilliant I will indeed nail I'm sure
you missed the car parks of the north
not a chance
let's take you back inside the gallery
I'm Colin Fraser is still in the glass
box let's just have a quick listening GU
be able to see on the shot there Ashish
Joshi has crept into the studio
alongside Colin bridge Yasuo perhaps
about to hear a little bit about what's
going on in terms of Sky News or and of
course 30 years ago became the second
ruling in the war we had a news channel
making the news channel and I've been
following the nine-nine it was trending
earlier on people are fascinated because
news is so 11 next season is me me me
coming to power inventing a phrase drop
down from the sky again online please
get to the graphics by John a little
graph coming in and showing what we
doing good expose us but we think the
opposite is true
intelli
that I'm gonna lose everything nobody
said to me there hey next you know ok
never getting slightly canal users we're
in the gallery looking at another
gallery that's talking to the presenter
who's talking about what's happening in
this gallery yeah this is that this is
all got a little bit matter hasn't
really running out going use raw white
on the white camera nine next start low
and wide again please nice guys so Colin
if you do a quick thank you to a she
shop the back of this and then straight
to the break the promos on they're still
Adam 30 seconds on the grab here they're
in a meeting to one but only in that
room 20 seconds you got 20 seconds for a
bit of banter between is your next three
to start your move
[Laughter]
the car keys behind-the-scenes of Sky
News you can the special one-off sky
channel 5 2 3 well let's move away show
again from gallery 21 and head down the
corridor to Sky News design of course a
lot what happens Katie on screen we've
been peeling behind the curtain today
but a lot of what happens on screen I
designed pretty much where you are yes
exactly and actually this is one of the
areas where there aren't any cameras so
we thought we'd take you here so that
you can have a little nosy around of
what they do here in the design
department Jill bear your graphics
editor aren't you so explain why your
role is so important what you do here in
graphics well I'm the liaison between
the newsroom and the graphics department
and basically we come up with clever
unique visually interesting ways telling
stories I mean the point of having
graphics is to simplify stories real
business and to provide clarity to
stories that sometimes might be a bit
difficult to either understand or to
break things down to more coherent
pieces parts so there's some examples
today of things that are running which
which sort of sum up that isn't there
the brexit yes so things that you
probably would have seen include our
brexit explainers about the backstop
which we've done numerous times about
resumes deal explaining Northern Ireland
from the sky we do things on not just on
TV but also on digital as well
so you probably would have seen our work
I mean the reason you don't have any
cameras here today and the reason it's
quite quiet is because these things that
you're producing they take a lot of time
to take a lot of concentration they do
you might not realize it but it takes
hours of work actually in order to get
graphics on the air something that's
sort of 30 seconds exactly
now it takes hours research it takes
time to approve scripts it takes time to
then come up with the concept that works
for a TV or on digital and then takes
time for the designer to actually make
it as well so it's not a very
straightforward process but hopefully
once you see it on screen you you know
it looks good yeah we'll leave you to it
she'll bear down oh it's got a very pin
- hello showing us around hello should
we reveal the secret as well yes
marriage the pair of them did you meet
her designs power couple yes yes we did
our eyes met across the gravity's ring
about the need for the need for design
to be about parity and about some flying
stories but there's also another big
part that design plays and that is in
branding you know that it's the wrapping
of what we do and also you will seen
because it's on TV now Sky News world so
that's us right now so it's a Nathan
here has been part of a team Nathan and
Callie designed all the stuff for Sky
News rules oh it was the it was the
brand that that wrapped everything up on
the day and my own personal claim to
fame is that's my handwriting
this is Photoshop is it that is
Photoshop year but we use different
Adobe after-effects yeah so we use some
nice things as well like this artist
which is what we used to build some 3d
graphics and also all our kind of screen
furniture that you see all the straps
and tickers and clocks and things all
build inside fees so that can be
flexible
and unlike After Effects they don't need
to be rendered they can just render on
the fly it can be painstaking work can't
it literally sort of your little
animating things by frame Wow yes right
yes I am you know there's there's an
enormous amount of care and precision to
what we do and that's why you don't want
any cameras I'm always well computer I
will hand you back to the life II then
to the newsroom so we move away from the
Sky News design back into the newsroom
was were crouching midday
you must by this point kind of got an
idea of the incremental way in which
things evolve here from that half-past
seven meeting in which stories were
mentioned there in the half nine meeting
where we were updated and of course
other bits of information that come
through then the output the production
meeting by other teams themselves
deciding how you to tell the story the
back-and-forth between the input and
output as they are trying to find the
correct right the right resources the
correct camera to do the story and then
what you're seeing at the moment the
kind of the ruling coverage after we've
moved away from the the Westminster
based on like politics sure you're
getting a real idea behind the scenes of
of the twists and the turns the concerns
everyone seems to be smiling in the
gallery today which is they're not
necessarily always the case coming in to
Colin Paisley of course will still be
anchoring that but this is a
high-pressure environment working in use
particularly working and in live news so
whilst you might see the director so it
might see the producer remaining in
there throughout the show they also do
change through the day you will tend to
find that the director will do one on
one
depending on them the demands of the
program as well and cut envision Sky
News president envisions the web an
onion address just going to finish this
hour with Colin Fraser I mean as you can
see we're all know already know looking
forward to that State of the Union
address by the US president later not
something that was mentioned in any
great amount of detail and half-past
seven meeting there's something and then
as we head through the day we'll
continue to get more prominent as we age
strengthening winds reaching this
mightier whether there'll be heavy
downpours but the rain would amount to
much of a central and southeastern
England a low cloud and well fog for the
hills as well but the west of mind will
have some they drive ten on my the rain
locally heavy moving eastwards overnight
becoming confined to southeast England
by derive most of the place or let me
drive the drain hours following the two
questions stereo bond per cup camera
next twenty stop talking now
and wipes a nice and T's here mics in
the envision this is guy whose
controversial comments made by the sting
gang stole tens dollar gator nine six
five four come into the bump three and
run one very nice
[Music]
and we are all fear for the 11 o'clock
car again
final preparations being made for the
twelve this is the point when I take my
leave ginge Decker's coming into the
gallery to take over but haven't you I
hope got a little bit of reason why I
generally tell not to work a half past
three in the morning with a big smile on
her face and it's and it's not just
because I've been in my bed for twelve
hours by that stage it is a fantastic
place to work surrounded by a lovely
bunch of people I just wish you might be
able to dip into a little bit more of
the language that is generally used but
you know we are Ofcom complying here at
Sky News so let's just watch its edge
towards the top of the 12 and I'll see
you on sunrise tomorrow let me just tell
you you will be your common vision in
our openers before we need a turkey just
to remind it to everyone to flap when we
change the key points to flag it out to
the director because I'm changing the
key points wise week yeah we've got one
I'm forward again hang on let's just
let's just reset Lee you do you know six
live pretty open okay thank you yeah
in the gallery okay boys Eldridge you've
got a questions the PM I didn't hear one
but there was a lot of breakup on the
feed understood I thought that was the
case so we will do a grab watching for
may enjoy then we will come to you for
your expecting just tell me when to
start when do I start walking off to the
after the when do I start walking
literally as you start saying this
really all right right the top think the
presenters aren't that bright
Jonathan Samuels there who is indeed a
very bright chap asking for information
about when to Walker
the surreal conversations that I had in
news galleries across the world
let's cross from this Danny's gallery to
Sky News Radio we're all very excited to
see Kip Bradshaw's home we haven't got
your mic party we can't see his hand
that's what we'll watch well kit does so
kit has to hit exactly 2 minutes you
will start bang on four o'clock and he
will finish bang on 402 because we're
going light commercial radio stations so
they were popped in for about two
minutes right well be quietly yep
it's kind of got a bit of fine there kit
but let's listen to his bulletin from
the sky News Center at 4:00 for children
aged between three and eight have been
killed in a house fire in Stafford a man
a woman and a baby are in hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries Bryan
Pickering lives around forty yards from
the property and raised the alarm
in here in the hours it's not yet known
how the blaze started Liam Neeson says
he was compelled by a primal desire for
revenge when he had repeated thoughts
about killing a black man after someone
close to him was raped the actor has
denied being a racist after being widely
criticized for his comments Theresa May
has suggested she's looking for a time
limit to the Irish backstop seek it
there as well as writing The Bulletin is
driving the bulletin desk himself as
well so playing out the clips that he's
presumably edited himself
customs union if there's no deal agreed
for Britain's future trading
relationship the Prime Minister has been
speaking in Belfast to reiterate her
commitment to avoiding a hard Irish
border a body has been found in a lake
by officers searching for a missing
University of Reading student 19-year
old Daniel Williams was reported missing
after a night out on the white knights
campus on Thursday the boss of the
Canadian firm which has bought HMV out
of administration says he paid a fair
price for the chain that won't reveal
how much it means a hundred stores will
be saved but 27 which don't make any
money have closed and Alex
oxlade-chamberlain has been named in
Liverpool's squad for the knockout
stages of the Champions League the
England international hasn't played
since April last year after suffering
multiple ligament damage to his knee
that's the latest from Sky News I'm kit
Bradshaw
great stuff kit Thanks last two minutes
I have to say I very briefly for a few
months did Sky News radio and it is a
terrifying thing to have to make sure
that you are time to the exact word and
I used to invariably end up halfway
through my name going it's Katie and as
you probably remember what we do is we
have all the back timings on our script
technique is that you've got the odd
line that you could add in or take away
yeah exactly and I have timed exactly
what times I should be hitting when I
get to each story so 108 122 134 and now
I knew when I got to the last story
which was about Alex oxlade-chamberlain
that I was a couple of seconds ahead of
myself so that you might have heard I
sort of started taking my time slow down
but if I needed it I had extra lines in
brackets so I could have told you more
about its knee injury if I didn t just
beforehand I don't know why I put that
as my interesting fact I was worked at
an Apple store and I was roped into
being a hand model but journalism will
leave you Jane on a shot of the hands
fairly fine set of hands that they are
interesting to think about the different
news agendas also which Sky News News
Channel LED on the story about brexit
well now here on profile you can see him
up at the right hand screen off little
editor talking to John Samuels in the
studio merced on the irish border on
radio they let on the house fire so
different stories for different markets
she knows - oh thank you so much I think
that some in the DB some in European
research group he's got grabbed Jonathan
Hale pick up Emily has now eat cupcakes
breaking news and she's looking ahead of
her own in order to see what's coming up
next she wants to go to Adele Robinson
he's one of our reporters he's out on
location so she was just buzzing through
on the intercom to the home desk there
to check that Adele is available and
that she's going to be able to bring her
up on the TV to this audience people
there will be some sort of backstop by
gravity that support galley throughout
the day an hour on our of the current
system that they're working on he's
looking ahead to the hour that he's on
screen on the hour that is Offspring
looking to help build that running order
and make sure that all the code here is
correct Phi's will pick up here 15
seconds box he's coding the next hour so
he'll be coming into the gallery at five
o'clock so he's now looking ahead to
that order
working out any particular codes that
need to be put in you'll be next okay I
follow you through all that stuff you do
Alan can you look at 70 for me mate
there's something not right sir pens
just asking Alan the co-director to just
look at something there's something
coming up in the running order that Ben
thinks doesn't look right because it's
all all
and coded a digit or a letter wrong can
control the whole system so Allen's now
looking ahead to work out what the issue
is next Johnathan's miking drop down on
nine back to the desk talking to Becky
Johnson out on location they're going to
be coming to her next standby going back
to the wall next hour six delayed you go
nine opening the wall standby OS 6
delayed the children again me and the
family are very well known and we can
see six-year-old Keegan with his
four-year-old sister Tilly she's gonna
even lose job as much as him they're not
here big graphic and a grab been the
directors now looking ahead to other
things that he's gonna have to do wild
back he's live is on air so he said that
she's gonna be talking to a graphic so
he has to make sure that that is cued up
if she's going to talk to any particular
clips from interviews he has to make
sure that's cued up and any images as
well that may be being used to float
over you can see that image just come up
on the sky screen just to make sure that
those images are in place as well she's
gonna read her
in the last few minutes and tributes
from the children's school teachers they
say Riley he was eight was a very common
in the government any of me do you see
us and he was a caring friend who hated
to see my darling I'm gonna come to you
next
just checking she was friendly and
carolien if John have been presenting in
you are next I've got no element it's me
to throw too it's just a straight up and
down
he was lively full of fun and mischief
with a really Indian school and everyone
who works with him loved him we were all
proud of the progress that he's made and
the teachers say it's very hard to
accept
well that's step away from the gallery
for now that is the ongoing output on
Scottie used to come away from that
house fire and Stafford back out in the
newsroom though katie has been doing the
rounds who are you worse now Katie I've
joined the evening team again to come
and see how it's all progressing Bayer
is one of the you're working as a
producer today also work as a reporter
for us as well I'm producing original
story and regional content original yeah
okay one thing you need is every good
journalist needs look at this notepads
come on
detailed notes of what you're working on
tonight there and how is it going what
is your responsibility then in the team
side so tonight I was first asked to
seeing the magnet magnate story so she
was doing a piece on fake news in Russia
and well--don't was really cut out in
Moscow my job is to make sure that it's
where it needs to be make sure that we
have
with the right name titles and the right
tags and essentially if anything goes
wrong I suppose it's down to me but yeah
that's that's my job today and also I
caught you in an edit suite a bit
earlier with Nick Phipps whose outfit
editor so it's it's you trekking with
Nick that everything exactly okay with
it it's a very collaborative process so
the piece comes in I go and speak to the
editor I make sure that again everything
is where it needs to be and if anything
it's not where it needs to be I sort of
instruct them what they need to do and
then once that's done and I feel is
acted and I standard I bring Nick in and
Nick basically says yes or no yeah I
mean we say the mode and you have to go
back and figure could I ask you as well
how long you've been here it's about
you're fairly new on you to working here
as a producer yes although you well I've
been the Sky News for six months but my
sort of career it's guys like four years
ago it says but this is what I love
about Sky News it's the brilliant way
that you can come here and get
experience and then come return and work
your way up so what were you doing four
years ago so four years ago I was a
school advisor at 80 and I joined Sky
Sports as an intern was here for a year
was amazing work across Spanish football
soccer and cricket various teams and
went away went into uni you know studied
journalism got loads of experience and
then the right opportunities came see
you came here you got you realized what
you needed in order to sort of get the
jobs that you wanted to do and then
you're back there again yeah and
obviously as well you know the great
thing about being involved with people
at Sky is that people kept an eye out
for me yes obviously I think I made a
decent impression and when opportunities
came up they you know pass through to me
and said would you like to have a part
of this or play a pie in there yeah so
anyone who is watching who is perhaps a
student and wanting to get in on the
ground it do you think it's really
helped to come and meet people and get
your face now you know go one it it
makes the difference if you come to me
people and get your face known to what I
did was I was doing things away from sky
and I think that impressed them and I
saw a local level was well not just at a
national level I was just showing that
you know what I've got the basic
instincts of you know to be a journalist
and I have the basic skills obviously
those have to be refined
if you just show any effort and you show
that you're you've got enterprise and
you've driven then that makes the right
impression but also skive actually
started going to universities and north
and outside of london they're looking
for students and they've actually made
me an ambassador to do that so great if
students if there are any students who
are interested in getting into
journalism email me let me if you have
any ideas
no come on touch email well my emails
baiyoke avenues of e ey a dot kab e lu @
sky dot UK and I'm very happy to give
advice help people out and share a
little bit say well thank you very nice
to meet you good luck with all the stuff
that you're seeing in and we'll let you
cross back to the live feed then we're
approaching the five o'clock hour when
Mark often was going to be taking over I
do fear Katie the bear may regret doing
it let's take you back to newsroom there
you can see mark Austin he's preparing
for his evening show tonight but also
later on this evening we're gonna be
crossing to Milbank and we're going to
be seeing scarlis strike which is on
from 7:00 until 9:00 presented of course
by Dermot Murnaghan that's the Milbank
editorial desk that's where the
political unit sits and there's David
lurking in the corner that is actually a
shared chair you heard it here first
Adam Bolton and Dermot Murnaghan hot
desk hot chair as Adam leaves Dermot
comes in so they share that space under
Brady is down there to talk us through
what happens in Milbank from that side
of the office the guests get in team and
the evening production team Enda hi jane
yeah let's go find out so we have all
our guests getting team here these are
the cameras by the way that you can see
all the newsroom on so they're remote
controlled
I've just seen it move all the wires and
cables and everything
that it needs to work and function and
the guests getting team we have Gemma
here first of all Gemma quick hello I
know you're busy what are you working on
Sky News tonight and I'm just looking
for a guest on the State of the Union
any ideas so far damn it's given me some
ideas so we've already got a former
media advisor for Trump as a pre record
so we're now looking for someone who's
more to the left so you'll have a couple
of guests brilliant from both sides of
the argument okay right we move along
Lucy is next Lucy what are you working
on all our politics with Adam Bolton for
tomorrow and we are looking at
definitely some political guests
probably have a guest on about the
Canada free trade agreement and also the
UK one there's an event tomorrow with
David Davis former brexit secretary in
Gregg hands we're havin to get an
interview with one of them so so will
Adam bring in tonight to give you
suggestions about guests or will you
lieges him usually we ladies with him we
have a chat with him before he leaves
after the show today and then it'll be
via email kind of his suggestions and
working on what what's what's happening
if anything obviously breaks or anything
changes then we can readjust good look
Thank You Lucy and finally cloudy is
here and she is working on an interview
that we recorded earlier on this is a
famous photographer yes Saddam
McCullen's
so myself and Dermot went to an
exhibition which she's doing at the Tate
and filmed interview of him this morning
so I'm now cutting it down all the best
bits of the interviews are the key
points or the key point is trying to
keep everything in but I'm hoping dermis
ask some good questions will go on
asking the dermis and where were you
today I've gone great I mean very
excited about the Dom McCullen interview
because he's I mean he's an absolute
legend you know 60 years in the business
Vietnam War basically every conflict
since the nineteen sixties and to
actually get to meet him was it was
incredible and I must say you know the
job at cloudy's doing is probably one of
the most difficult that anyone will ever
had because I got so excited doing the
interview and the fact is that we were
pre recording it so you kept talking we
had we kept talking well he keeps
talking as well but every single
he says he's a gem now you and I know
that when you do an interview you listen
as a reporter thinking roughly if you've
got to cut it down we won't use that bit
enough it's really good
we've gone 20 minutes every word an
absolute gem so cloudy and I you know
discussing really that the hardest part
is what what you leave out to get it
down to kind of broadcast Lang I'm just
every anecdotes every story that you can
see the photographs on the walls behind
him in the gallery as he talks about
those in particular desert as a
shell-shocked Vietnam Marine isn't there
who he takes a photograph of just after
a shell has dropped which nearly got in
thankfully Don survives so did the
Marine but he was so shocked that he
said he took five shots of the Marine as
US he kind of retired got it got off the
scene and the Marine didn't blink once
because he was gone and it's in those
eyes that you actually see the horror of
the vietnam war without actually seeing
any blood and gore any guts amazing
photography so your time frame of the
day a lot of the day's political events
have already happened a lot of the news
has happened in the day and you're
wrapping up in the evening you've you've
got a great kind of period of time yeah
reflect on the day and we know pretty
much what's gonna be on the front pages
tomorrow and we also do have a great
location as well in that we're out just
across the road from Westminster so you
know on the big political days we've
having an awful lot of those recently
you know we get out we can get a stream
of the politicians in here and interview
them face to face which which really
makes a heck of a difference it must be
said today though you know the political
action brexit actions taking place in
northern ireland so our political
lettuce faisal islam so doing that so
we're touching wood pretty brexit light
and heist like all of you you've been
broadcasting a long time hmm have you
ever seen anything like sky news run off
a long time anything seen anything like
it's gonna use wrong i mean what what is
known today cameras coming in everyone
being interviewed no nothing like it at
all but you know that's part of Sky News
you know the thing is that thirty years
ago we thought we were innovating we
were you know innovating by just doing a
24-hour channel now it seems
commonplace and during the discussions
I've been having during the course of
this week about the future the news
people keep referring to us as legacy
broadcasters mainstream media so you
know we're just showing people hey you
know we can do an awful lot of other
things as well and if you you want to
see how we make these decisions if you
want to disagree with them but certainly
if you want to understand how they come
about what appears on your screen what
appears on your phone what appears on
line this is how we do it what advice
would you give to any young person out
there at college or university one thing
to get into the media and wondering if
it's something that they can achieve or
would even want to go and do yeah I'd
say you know you did mention how long
I've been there I've been in the media I
mean I started in an old group going
through newspapers and whatever there
are many different routes in but I think
the formula stays the same and it goes
for all of us all my colleagues here at
Sky News funded camera behind camera is
you know pursue a passion be interested
learn how to communicate and and follow
that through don't necessarily think I
have to be this that all the other
follow those through if it really is
journalism for you there are many
different routes in it doesn't
necessarily have to be papers radio or
TV as it was in my day now there are
many many other ways in but at the end
of the day I would also say try and get
paid for it because if you want to make
a career out of it there are many ways
that I see nowadays people to produce
some pretty good quality journalism you
know particularly online and you know
you wouldn't be able to live off it it's
still a great time to be in the business
oh absolutely yeah I was originally a
historian by training and I spent now
looking back at it too long doing it
many many years doing postgraduate
attempts and and I suddenly realized
there's an old cliche about journalism
that you have a front row seat at the
making of history now I hate cliche but
that's one I will buy into it's
absolutely true I mean the things that
I've seen in the 35 years I've been in
the business is quite unbelievable
that's brilliant Dermot thanks for your
time I couldn't have put it better
myself a front row seat in the making of
history and 30 years of Sky News history
today so Sky News raw I'm gonna leave
you with a shot of our Milbank newsroom
everyone just going about their day
it has been a busy day a lot of the
action happened in Downing Street we
started off with cabinet arrivals and
then there was the Prime Minister
heading off to Belfast giving that
speech and there we have beth Rigby
let's actually just go and we'll grab a
quick word with Beth and Beth is never
short of anything to say so Beth tell me
yeah what's gonna be on the front pages
tomorrow I don't know you know I do know
everything come on I've been deep in
I've been deep in thought doing a sky
views column today it's gonna be on the
website tomorrow a preview what about
what you think it's about what might our
exit I think on the front page tomorrow
will be whatever happened in Ireland
today I think actually the Prime
Minister had maybe a little glimmer of
hope today because Ireland fostering the
DEP sort of seemed to suggest that she
might help her out on the issue of this
Irish backstop well I was in Downing
Street and I saw some members of the DUP
coming out they did not look very happy
nay they did not look very face it's
like thunder well Arlene Foster the mood
music I think was a quite positive for
the prime minister from her something
new him something has shifted today
maybe she might just be chipping away it
she's going to Brussels I think later
this week as well but I've spoken to
lots of brexit ears as well and they're
saying she's got to get that withdrawal
agreement that's the international
treaty that is our exit deal from the EU
that she's got to get that reopened and
renegotiate that we've got 50 days to go
and yet Brussels have said no and also
it's taken two years to negotiate it so
that's why some people would say that
her going to process is riding off on a
unicorn that this is fantasy politics
look she's probably going to come back
with something the question is can she
get enough of her brexit ears to get it
through the commas adam bolton thinks
she can and i always agree with that and
volson there we go we're in Milbank and
he is the king of this palace a lot of
the time so we'll have to agree without
embolden back to you Jane a fantastic
day's coverage here in Westminster on
Sky News rod thanks sender
you can see enter just there on the
monitor in the middle of your screen
there this is the newsroom if you've
been watching us all day one why aren't
you doing something else but two it has
to be compelling viewing lots of people
are saying that they are absolutely
tuned to us if you watch it from 7:00
o'clock this model of restarted the
newsroom was a little bit quieter than
it is now throughout the day it's been
interesting to see how stories have
developed now the big push is ahead to
the five o'clock program friended by
Mark Austin there's the head of News
John Riley talk to Michael fall the head
of social and digital are they treating
each other are they texting each other
we've had lots of people asking this
questions we were asked what a slab was
a while ago a slab is a chunk of video
or a chunk of interview that we put out
on air somebody wanted to know what sky
saucers means when we talk about sky
sauces it's when one of our reporters
has taken somebody that they trust that
they believe or they may have seen a
document with her own eyes but it hasn't
been officially announced so for example
a good example would be buck climene's
exclusive on some day that the people
and miss Ann were going to be told that
the x-trail wasn't going to be built
there it was sky sources on Sunday it
was announced officially by Nissan on
Monday Neil Dunwoody they're talking to
john riley milton were the head of
output
there's Francesca who is coming to the
end of her shift
she's been outputted anything throughout
the whole day here on Sky News she gets
in really early in the morning goes to
all the early morning meetings and works
out which stories were going to be
covering throughout the day on Sky News
a little sneaky fact about Francesca her
brother told her to put some makeup on
after she appeared on the telly earlier
this morning she doesn't need it as
Darren over the last hour we've seen him
building the running order and assisting
the produced from building the running
order cuz he's one of the directors he's
gonna be going in at five o'clock into
the gallery so he's checking that the
coding it's right on each of the slugs
that's put into the running order
because if the coding isn't right it
won't go on the telly and it just takes
a digit or a letter to be wrong and it
doesn't work
mark Austin there of course he's got
about half an hour to go before his
program starts so this last half an hour
before you go on air it's quite a
crucial time for a presenter you're
going through your notes that you've
made since you've been in you love satin
read some articles done some background
and you have written some questions so
it's a chance for you to perhaps go over
and review questions you've asked you're
going to ask what answers you think you
might get what supplementary questions
you could maybe have any extra
background reading that you want to do
and then if you've got time you then get
to go through all the script so going
through rewritings quick tweaking
scripts putting them in your own words
make it easier to read for you and that
goes on while you're there as well you
know presenters read ahead we often on
the lunchtime shift read ahead to see
what scripts are coming up and how we
can alter them
just to know that we can cross to
Washington now we've been across the UK
today but now we're going across the
world Becky Cottrill is across there for
us this is sky News's Washington studio
hi Becky give us a tour hi yes so this
is the office in our Washington bureau
just have a little look around it's
quite small there's only actually six of
us here in DC so this desk here is where
I sit I am one of the producers so it's
my job to work with a correspondent so
we're putting together TV packages
planning stories and what are the main
difficulties we face is trying to plan
stuff where we can get out of DC speak
to people see how they're feeling often
about the president but also having to
cover the on the day news so often we'll
have a conversation in the morning see
what the president's doing there are
kind of many multiple news lines on any
day depending on from what Trump's up to
and kind of how he's been behaving
recently so I often will be kind of
looking at this monitor watching what
Trump's up to they'll be kind of
unscheduled press conferences that we'll
have to look out for and we kind of have
to think about how much time we
designate to the president and you know
the things that he often uses to do to
distract the media from unfavorable
coverage and also you know responding to
things like shootings or just you know
other big stories that are playing out
big across the network's here one of the
most kind of memorable Trump incidents
of recent times was when he had that
very bizarre meeting with Kanye West in
the Oval Office so we all gathered round
one screen and kind of watched in
amazement as the two had this pretty
bizarre encounter I don't know if you
remember it was well worth watching back
and then over here we've got with a
correspondents it's so Cordelia and
Amanda Amanda is actually away in
Venezuela at the moment and Cordelia is
in the edit suite I'll take you in there
in a moment and then over here she's not
here right now but this is where Emily
sits she is the bureau chief and she's
in charge of the DC operation as well as
New York and LA where we also have teams
now I will take you through it there's
Emily very busy woman so this is our
edit suite so in here we've got Dickon
and
dicken is one of our cameramen so he
shoots everything you see and edits
everything you see and him and Cordelia
are working on a interview they did
earlier tell us a bit about it very
closely with Sara Huckabee Sanders he's
left the White House and it's really
intriguing
he's quite open and candid about his
time working there talks about some of
his regrets about learning about the
president's policies from tweets and
having to try and manage the message and
a bit about the State of the Union which
of course is tonight as well so quite
open and frank which is good good so
they're working on this now as you can
see we've got these screens above us so
that's all the feeds we have coming in
whether it's President Trump in the
White House or politicians on the hill
over at Congress and over here
so you it might not you might not get
sense of it this is an extremely small
room and over here is where the
correspondents will often do their live
hits this is the background we have it's
not as exciting as what I'm going to
show you in a moment up on the roof so
kind of depending on how busy it is on
any given day we've got an edit space
there and edit space there so we've got
an edit going on a correspondent could
be doing live hit so it can all get a
bit chaotic
especially when Trump throws a curveball
late afternoon and we all have to
scramble and I will in a second be
taking you up on the roof and that's a
nice view of the Capitol building in the
background Becky thanks very much for
that great to see all the team in
Washington not seen some of them for
quite a long time so it's lovely to see
who's behind the scenes and what the
Washington bureau looks like we're used
to seeing the reporter but we don't get
to see all the people who are behind the
scenes making it all happen well what
about where it all happens here in West
London and this is not the news
operations center this is where all the
images from elsewhere come in foreign
bureaus satellite trucks digitally and
also other live interviews come in and
as these images come in the people in
nor clays with the gallery so they let
the gallery and the home desk and the
foreign guests know
if important images have come through
that they think should be going over
telly or that they know people are
waiting for so it's a really crucial
Center Katie sent Spencer is there for
us with Lisa Watson I believe the
manager of Scot knees knock she's been
ducking and diving out of the cameras
today she's been you've called it a
Katie it was the only way we were going
to actually get to talk to her worries
he's been dodging cameras all day Lisa
very camera shy person normally yes I
guess that's part of the joy of today
isn't it I know everyone who will
normally be on TV see what each other
and the other manager I mean it's a huge
Bank of sort of feeds that we can see
coming in in front of you guys yeah is
that what you guys are doing watching a
lot of TV yeah there is a huge Bank you
get very used to kind of noticing one
thing is going wrong because kind of the
kind of change what have you but it's
amazingly it is in a organized so that
sure there's incoming fees coming on one
side outgoing fees going on the other so
you get you learn to know which way to
look so we could probably find me I mean
if we just sort of quickly sort of look
over here it looks like one of your team
are they setting them yes Skype yeah Tim
Dee is doing a Skype guest which is
going to be on the news channel shortly
so he's just lined up the guest to
obviously waiting to go on it making
sure they clearly hear correctly and
once everything this type said the
important thing is that vision and good
comms were established so that everybody
can hear each other and get feels
comfortable so we're the first point of
contact so we introduce ourselves say
who we are say you're going to be on air
you know we're going to put you two at
the gallery so I hope you reassure them
so it can be very nerve-wracking
experience being on air yes we try to
stay away from Skype so if we can't know
because sometimes the delays can just be
so yeah aenthul and that's one of the
things that you guys have to dial in and
dial in again to see if it's right and
also depending on the region you're in
your broadband might connection but it
relies on broadband so your connection
could be amazing or it could be a little
bit different okay so if you've got kind
of family and friends watching kind of
things upstairs or streaming online that
could really news
tell your children would you mind not
going online for five minutes so I'm
just gonna pure ones go I knew something
like that so that's how it works talk us
through who else we've got here what
other people are doing what is one of
the NOC supervisors along with Richard
Westwood
so rod lebryk is on a late shift today
and he has been responsible for
supporting a lot of the a lot of the
sauce feeds for your gallery 800 last
off now so it's been a bit of a flurry
hasn't it rod if so it's been a busy day
the normal yeah so this chap here is
Nick sparks then he plays a big role in
because he's the voice before you came
to us we had some issues which was the
reason that we were delayed
communications comes in our air at the
moment I'm getting a feed at the gallery
that are going to be talking to me but
when we sort of tests whether or not
we've got comms there is an ident your
voice which says which repeats over and
over again and drives you slightly crazy
until you actually get to hear your papa
gallery but so that that's a big part of
it though isn't it communication with
people out in the field
exactly so making sure you've got
communication and comms so if you dial
up and you don't obviously hear anything
then instantly there's a problem so
first thing you generally do
it's called us and we sort it out make
it happen yeah and so what what are you
guys doing at the moment we're looking
right so I think you can get a sneak
preview of what's about to happen next
so this is the team in Washington who
just gone to our rooftop so this is
getting terribly confusing behind they
just relocate and so I'm just making
sure that it's all stable and it works
so far so good
well in that case perhaps we should
cross across to Washington then in that
case thank you thank you hi yes so
welcome welcome back to Washington so
the last time you saw us we were in our
kind of slightly grotty to be honest
edit suite downstairs now we're on the
roof of our building and in the
background we've got the Capitol
building which is probably kind of the
most iconic building associated with the
political wrangling here in Washington
this is where our reporters do their
lives as much as possible so this is sky
News's spot
either Cordelia or Amanda our
correspondents will stand here the
Capitals in the background tonight we'll
also have Greg up here so it's president
Trump's State of the Union address
that's an annual thing where he goes
over there and speaks to the congressmen
and women and the Senators and kind of
tells them how he thinks the country is
doing under his leadership apparently
his message is gonna be all about kind
of bringing people together and you know
cutting through the divisive nough so
we'll see how that goes down and as you
can see looking across here we've got
other live spots that the other networks
use so we share this with the likes of
Fox News and MSNBC who are American
networks obviously and then Channel 4
News and ITV News also have spaces up
here so the reporters have very much
have to stand in their spot and kind of
drone out the sound of the other
correspondents if they're doing lives at
the same time and tonight will be
particularly busy with states of the
union if you look again you can see some
of the network's have already got their
spots set up in preparation and so
that's 8 p.m. local time so we'll be
reporting on that live and into sunrise
so morning time in the UK and if you
look over here this isn't so glamorous
you can see lots of kind of untidy wires
and chairs strewn across this is where
the cameraman would kind of keep all
their equipment and it might not look
too hot now I'm in a coat but it kind of
gets unbearably hot in the summer and
you can often see pasty looking British
and American cameramen taking shelter
under there in between lives so that
they don't get sunburned and this is
obviously where we were to plug in for
our lives and the cameramen would have
to come up early and get connection with
London and make sure that it's all okay
before the live and then just finally
I'm going to point out we've got a giant
American flag on our roof space now that
is a very common sight in America they
are incredibly patriotic and if you look
you probably can't see but as I look out
across here all the buildings have stars
and stripes on them and at times you
know of national mourning
most recently I'm thinking of the death
of George HW Bush the former president
the president will order for these flags
to be lowered to half-mast so they'll
all go down and I think that's pretty
much it from here in Washington
thanks so much that was really really
great and great see drew fair up at West
in Washington and it is I can attest
very very windy very cold winter and
blindingly hot in the sunshine right
we're back here in West London this is
the newsroom
a lot of energy throughout the day has
been going into what's going to happen
in the next 20 minutes or so the five
o'clock hour with Mark Austin a lot of
energy going into packaging for that and
into getting some good guests for that
you can just see Katy they're walking
through in the middle of the newsroom
again it's been interesting for those
you've been watching it throughout the
day how stories have developed
throughout the day stories that were
first mentioned this morning Liam Neeson
was a story that was bubbling around a
little bit this morning by mid-morning
it really ramped up and then we got a
new interview from him this afternoon
and it's moved up the running order
throughout the day because of what's
happened to it interesting also when you
look at these shots of the newsroom how
the different outlets have taken the
same story and used it differently so
we've seen Sky News leading on a
different story to Sky News Radio and
those in town will be different stories
that will be the top click stories on
mobile or on the iPad etc
back at the foreign desk now it's Justin
Bo's and K and we were hearing from
Carol earlier who is the head of our
international operations about the
significance of the foreign desk it's a
really tricky job working on the foreign
desk you've really got to know your
stuff
it's not just understanding about UK
news obviously it's about knowing
international news knowing who are the
people to call in different countries
when a story may unexpectedly happen
there's Neil Dunwoody he is head of
output head of the output editors I
think we're hoping to talk to Neil
actually he's playing it quiet at the
moment
so down the director that we were
watching earlier who hopefully will have
built the next hour by now and have
checked it for any glitches but a lot of
attention at the moment being focused on
what's actually going out on the telly
let's talk to some of the daytime output
team Katie's there with Andy Milburn I
think let's just let them let the camera
circle hi Katie hi Andy hello yes so
what time were we on at the moment so
we're about 20 to 5 o'clock busy time
for those people like Andy who's
assistant editor today who is building
rundown for 5:00 on here how's it going
has anything changed is everything sort
of fairly in place we're looking in a
really good shape actually the program's
pretty much done I've checked everything
up until about 10 past 5:00 so that's
pretty good is there a VT that's running
in the fibers worse we've got two VT two
stories which we have been doing as live
stories throughout the day which we're
doing V T's on four five o'clock these
are beauties from scratch so in the work
that they've worked in the works in edit
Suites V T's are always the most
stressful thing to get on air they take
a very long time and there's a question
mark as to whether or not they will
actually make this is the exciting time
of day isn't it so we're going to just
quickly thank you Andy have a chat to
Francesca the output editor is that what
you've been doing it been going oh yes
I've been in one of the other Suites
looking at Bethenny's piece which is
almost there they're just making a few
final touches to the other piece the
inwards piece is coming on but I haven't
had a chance to watch it yet so
sometimes when it is down to the wire we
do a thing called hot rolling tape
that's right let's hope there aren't any
this evening but if I could well be like
I said I haven't been able to watch the
words piece
and is it I mean it's sometimes we're
packaging for five sometimes we're
packaging for seven are please so it's
depending on when the footage is
available how the story's gone
throughout the day I mean with Stafford
obviously it's been an awful story but
we heard from the emergency services and
we've heard from neighbors so the
elements of that it's just about making
sure that we can meet Edison sometime as
the news agenda changed much day I know
you were waiting for Theresa mates as a
speaker so it's been kind of as we
thought it would go Theresa mames very
good very strong in the back stop so
we've got that top staffers like I said
is a really emotional story the Liam
Neeson has had us all talking in the
newsroom all day and Ian's got some
great elements for that including the
John Barnes interview that we did
earlier patting guard and we've been
getting some good lines from that now so
so you know there have been any major
major unexpected developments maybe we
should go and take a look and see how
are you I'm right okay let's take you
down the edit corridor and we can see
whether or not they sweetie is probably
going to be published on time or whether
they're going to have to do a thing
called hot rolling which I will explain
to you when we go in there so edit one
Belinda is in here and she is the person
that we always come to ask what edit
suite we need to go into so we're
looking for Ian woods edit suite it's
the next door room to hear some people
but it's only of two extra rooms so we
will come this way oh no one in the
inwards right so we may have to be quiet
and we might be able to stay that long
depending on how high pressured the
situation is at the moment in words I'm
sorry you're lying on Sky News roar at
the moment I'm is this pressure the the
VT is due to guard at five plus five
we've got twenty minutes which is a life
time in Tel Aviv
except except except when you're an
editor like janitor but we are we are we
are pretty much finished
but being perfectionist we'd like to
sort of fiddle around with with things
and there's an interview which I think
should be props higher up in the report
which we're still toying with a way of
kind of swap things around so there's
always debate right up until airtime if
the camera can sort of spin around to
see what Jen's over at the moment this
is a black holes in there which is the
main thing there's pictures covering
everything so now it's just sort of
tweaking and finessing is it we were all
done and ready
someone said some very interesting
things that we thought the story Jen can
I ask you if you have got timers yeah
hot rolling what so hopefully we're
going to publish this it will be dropped
into the rundown what is hot rolling and
because that is if we don't have enough
time to publish it yeah hot rolling is
when instead of all the redundancy of
publishing a flattened file and then
going into the system and then a very
sturdy machine playing it out on air
instead we just dial up the gallery and
we play it and they just record from our
screen and it goes straight out so it
can be literally Mark Austin would be
reading the intro link and the director
in the gallery would say okay we're and
we're talking to them saying make the
entry longer and you just have to hit
the spacebar and play it out straight
away yeah that is a scenario that we
want to at all costs avoid no we don't
want to miss our slot that's what that's
the main thing has this story changed
much from how you thought it would be
yeah you want to carry on with us here
isn't getting done yes because this
morning when we had our morning meeting
we didn't really expect frankly to have
Liam Neeson we thought we'd still be
talking about the audio clips from the
original interview so the fact that he
was appearing on Good Morning America I
think he was already booked he's on the
media tour at the moment so he was
booked to do this this sloth
promoting a film and ABC were saying
they were credit to you for still
turning up and doing the interview
despite all the backlash that he's had
over the past 24 but when we were
planning the story we thought the the
ingredient we probably wouldn't have was
Liam Neeson so you're building other
elements around it and having built
those other elements you still want to
keep as many of those elements as
possible so for example we decided that
we wanted to talk to someone who's
involved in the publicity side of things
in crisis management how do you deal
with a situation like this so we went to
Dominic Moen who's a former editor of
the son who's done lots of junket
interviews in the past and knows how
bland they normally are and can talk in
that context but can also advise now
that he's working as a crisis management
consultant about what he should do now
this is a typical story for that I often
end up with where you're pulling
together different elements from
different places so you've got interview
in America you've got an interview with
John Barnes the former England football
we're talking about this who's in the
northwest of England I'm in London you
always kind of want your reporter to be
somehow seem to be involved in the story
as opposed to just spending all this
time in an edit suite so I made a point
of driving into central London did an
interview with with Tom Owen which
actually makes like a 12-second
soundbite in the piece but takes up
three hours of your time driving no no I
don't think people are aware of how much
effort goes into I mean you're very
close now there is just the final sort
of tweaks what we got with God seriously
in 12 minutes I've changed the entire
tops of packages yeah you can do that
kind of thing but we're not in that kind
of situation it is a finessing
operation at the moment we've got all
the interviews in there we've got
someone criticizing Liam Neeson
understandably we've got John Barnes
defending Liam Neeson we've got some be
advising Liam Neeson and we've got the
man himself so all that is crammed into
a package which is just under three
minutes I think isn't it scary thing
when you find it three minutes ten and
you have to try we may try and reduce it
in duration for later on because
programs later in the evening we leave
you to it then I sense that we've come
into the knowing time because you do
need to check these you might imagine
that under your tender
stayed stagnant Ian and will hand you
back to the live feed then see then you
can get these final moments building up
to the five o'clock hour
thanks very much Casey at great stuff
today really given us a real insight
into different roles of different people
in the newsroom you can see it was dark
we started this morning the someone's
just coming up it's just getting dark
again as the sun's going down again
there needs to be a lot busier now it
cost us five and it was at 7:00 o'clock
this morning when we started it's
broadcasting Sky News Raw if you're just
tuning in you just missed it the reason
we're doing this today is because it's
our 30th birthday thirty years today
that Sky News began and so because of
that we have been broadcasting from 7:00
a.m.
behind the scenes we've got 32 cameras
around the newsroom we've brought to you
reports from our Washington bureau from
correspondents out in the field and from
our building studios as well just to try
and help you understand how we put out
the news it's Guyanese how many people
are involved where decisions are made
who they're made by when they're made
we've been in quite a lot of the key
meetings throughout the course of today
the early morning 7 o'clock 7:30
editorial meetings story meetings
throughout the day and we've sat in with
production teams and listen to them as
they've talked about the different
stories how they're going to treat them
we've followed reporters like Ian woods
on a story throughout the course of the
day and we've been in and out of the
gallery throughout the course of the day
as well
you see Francesca in the middle of the
room there she's just walking away with
the dark hair she is looking ahead to
the five o'clock news program she's in
charge of the daytime outfit on Skye so
this is the last few minutes before the
program and goes on quite a tense time
she's got Andi sitting next to her
they're working together
it's not a nightmare isn't going to see
if Martha Kudo I mean at least market
force so Francesca's now talking to Paul
Harrison on the news desk Paul has been
a bit of a regular feature of Sky News
always popped into life yeah but he's in
charge of the home desk he's in charge
of deploying reporters and crews across
the UK let's do it just before Hatton
Garden I'd say where you've put it
that's perfect so they're just working
out the timings of when one of their
live reports are going to be on GG check
with Paul that it's okay to put the
personnel at that time also been
liaising with the foreign desk today the
five o'clock news program of course in
the afternoon just america's woken up
now so we often get a lot more american
news of course LG with trump venezuela
is also featuring relatively highly on
the running orders today we saw Andy in
the afternoon meeting this month this
afternoon talking about their stories
and that's across the road it's guy
central and there's my costume you just
see him living out the back of shots he
has just arrived at the glass box it's
where we broadcast from throughout the
day throughout the week at Sky News he's
there he is just walking on the walkway
to the production desks getting his
microphone on presumably doing the final
bits of prep I'm sure he doesn't know
we're watching him I hope he doesn't do
anything embarrassing I'm sure he won't
I'm just going to go and check on the
pieces and you just double-check the top
sequence again for us
so Francesca the produced there's
running off down the edit corridor
obviously going to check on the progress
of that piece there's Belinda she's in
charge of editing at the moment she said
even edit one so Francesca the bruise
there
and ingested on the foreign desk they
would have made sure that any of the
reporters that we're planning to cross
to this hour in our international
bureaus are aware and that they are
ready to go Franchesca now just got
ahead in that edit so let's check on the
progress Thomas the producer in there
giving an idea of when it will be ready
oh six minutes - are there Oh Nora will
you give Sophie the guest details think
we are you happy with key points it was
all look good that's the body Mulder
yeah pop them in yeah
so that gun Christine okay
have you written it in yes
they're publishing now if we need to who
might just have to flip them over
because I think words he's gonna be
there before Johnson that Stephen
Stephen should use that time can we
write you sure Stephen mark was up in
plenty of time please thank you
five minutes till we go on air now
they're just publishing now so I don't
have the package yet okay but no the
package as long as there's nothing as
long as there's no problem with a
package okay all right any questions
about the six just super all right thank
you thank you
no it's not so Francesca and the
director Darren now making the way into
the gallery in here Francesca's constant
pen clicking nervousness
Emily's counting off air 22 plus
Austin's reason says she won't allow is
there by camera 12 12 7 mix surprise
standby promo three two one
[Music]
overall it's positive itself off red
again oh but it's still on air mark
Austin's now just making his way into
the glass box
so Jonathan Samuels they're just logging
out he's been on air for the last three
hours great and now they have to change
the desk around and get it all ready for
the five o'clock show yeah good good one
well I see same time Cheers
three minutes to warm ass
oh my - I know I know it's upside-down
sorry
there's my time Marcus tower yeah smart
for Jessica just checking you can hear
me oh yeah
great stuff you'll see we have now got a
bricks that guests at half five the
briefs out on email for you yeah and
just to confirm it's gonna be Stephen
Murphy at the top not Faisal two minutes
to the I don't roll - okay so it's a
professor of sort of British and Irish
history two minutes to one hour exactly
can talk to us about the significance of
the backstop yeah I'm the Good Friday
Agreement yeah yeah just give us a bit
of context and talk about some of those
things we discussed what are the
solutions yeah two minutes to go before
we get Stephen we we've got the may grab
and the key points to go through yeah
okay how long is the major thanks just
the gallery in London can hear me are
you good to go it's a little all quiet
but you hear the iron trolling in a
minute thank you a one minute to the
island roll we've just got about a
minute to go here on Sky News roar
thanks for joining us today
what goes on behind the scenes live at
Sky News to celebrate our 30th birthday
it's been a real blast watching it and
thanks for joining us